two welcome back everybody it's been a
crazy long weekend but we're back for a
new season there's been so much that has
happened so we just want I want to get
right into the news because so much has
happened let's catch up on all the great
things that we missed right into the
news Andrew Tate is once again being
lauded for his continued contributions
to Human Rights everywhere as he
continues to Champion equal
opportunities for women and all who are
disenfranchised in this patriarchal
system when they're the latest
achievement the Nobel Peace
earlier this morning
meanwhile an ongoing development
Stateside animal activist Logan Paul
continues his strike against factory
farming
all further killings
big slaughterhouse the nation
as some refer to Mr Paul's actions as
eco-terrorism others describe him as a
hero for pigs everywhere and fine are
you guys tenured professor of literature
what is happening right now this is not
right bestseller flowers for Aiden
Ross has recently been promoted dice
Aiden is illiterate how is he gonna
write a book
for the new Dean what are you talking
about referred to as the voice of a
generation I don't know what a 21st
century Mark Twain what we will be
following this story closely for further
developers this doesn't make any sense
what is happening
oh
what's happening
okay
okay
what the where am I
oh
ah welcome to the desert of the real
what what's happening who are you it's
me it's Dan it stands word love your
producer we got a show to do ela's
waiting right over there
yeah dude I gave you the red pill like a
month ago and you've just been like
sleeping this whole time usually this
takes like this is like a five minute
process
even late waking up out of the Matrix
dude
let's go
all right
that's nasty [ __ ] I'm getting Tomatoes
tomatoes in the chat dude
hello hello
we're back
yeah I hope you guys that all enjoyed
that little goof of course the Matrix
been a big topic of conversation
apparently it's real now we thought it
we when I was a kid it was just a movie
but now it is it's real old man it's
actually become like this crazy Alpha
red pill thing and I can't get enough of
it I love it it's the greatest meme I've
been tweeting [ __ ] like
The Matrix maybe [ __ ] my pants oh
because they keep being like Oh The
Matrix is out to get you like Logan Paul
tweeted out he goes after he was getting
like destroyed publicly for the scamming
and the pig thing yeah he goes the
Matrix is real pray it never comes after
you
like okay bro
sure is then I I think I tweeted
something like my finger just slipped
through the toilet paper and I fingered
my own butthole The Matrix got me again
I saw that laughs
oh thank you to our sponsors honey and
stamps.com and thank you and welcome
back to everybody at home it's so nice
to be back I got to be totally honest
you guys it's just nice to see all and
be here it's been a long vacation all
different flavors and there's all
different flavors
there's so much has happened I know it's
crazy because the last show we did was
the live live show so we never actually
debriefed on that
um by the way here's the toy this
[ __ ] dude actually tweeted this [ __ ]
The Matrix is real preview never become
its Target
the [ __ ] dude
so I'm kind of at a uh lost for words
right now
right oh yeah yeah here here's this is
my take on The Matrix there's been so
many funny memes still the makers just
made my finger slip through the toilet
paper and figure my butthole
this [ __ ] is awesome dude you've seen
these yeah
that's the real Morpheus right there
you have one you have two options Aiden
yeah so
how's everybody doing how's everybody's
break been it's been almost a month
we've been gone and um
talk to me what's going on it's been
good it's been good it was a relaxing
break uh and uh this last week
pretty much
second half of the last week was getting
pretty bored it was kind of like let's
let's get back to the show we're like
the summer Blues exactly exactly I was I
was just kicking around uh my girlfriend
Allison is out of town right now too so
I'm just like wandering I'm like the
jacket pop jacket off
are you jacking offing a lot that's
right yeah I got my house to myself baby
Zach still got it he's still got it he's
still got it oh that's good are you
playing any games you're watching any
shows what are you what are you doing
all the regular stuff you know
um but enough about me I mean what does
everybody else open up oh damn by the
way I got a um steam deck oh my God
right you mentioned that last night
that's pretty cool I don't I don't
enjoying it too long but steam has this
handheld console where you can play your
steam pc games on the house that's the
game
Zach's still got it that's the guy it's
awesome it's super fun but anyway yeah
anyway anything else uh let's see lean
we have a lot of kind of Lena had a
viral moment
um let's pull this up Lena had a tick
tock that went Mega viral life hack life
hack wait how many views did it get I
got to pull up 7.8 million
7.8.8 million dude wow
strongly about this yeah wait where is
it I scroll down a little bit oh you
made a lot of tick tocks wait why you
made all this you made all these what
the hell you've been doing two to three
a day what oh there it is it's our New
Year's resolution second there
life hack
we're wearing Dr Martin wait and we're
gonna get a claimed there's like really
soft music in the back
not if I go
there you go
cut off the tips like this
I found this on Tick Tock thank you
so so did you guys notice something like
I didn't even notice it when I watched
it I didn't apparently she called it Dr
Martens Martin yeah well Dr Martin you
but you said you said Martin funny too I
think Martin you like Martin people
commenting about that but I don't I
didn't understand that what's wrong with
Martin yeah you see you did it again
Martin Martin
well when you say it quickly do you say
Martin or do you say Dr Martin Martin Dr
Martin you do that at the same way no I
don't even know Dr Martin Martin's Dr
Martin will you say it say it Lena Dr
Martin I don't know there's something
about the way you say it maybe you hit
that last man yeah you go Dr Martin
flavors flavors say flavors flavors
flavors yeah you go you're good but any
well it resonated because people were
losing their mind they were loving this
[ __ ] Tick Tock so I think that in
Israel we say the same thing I think we
say doctor I don't think saying that
right now in Israel that way yeah
I didn't even think about it twice wow
the whole country of Israel's cringe
courage
Dr Martin yeah so many people may do
whatever uh making fun of her it was it
was it was kind of entertaining to watch
them I didn't think they were making
funny it seemed like all love wouldn't
it no some people were really upset they
were saying I should be wearing Dr
Martens if I don't know how to say the
name oh yeah
fake fan it isn't it more like a slang
way of saying it because like it's not
like you're saying an incorrect thing
right she disrespected that that good
doctor's name I don't think it's a big
deal to say it like that but I will but
I will say it's somebody that's been
wearing those shoes for 20 plus years
they're docs I've never heard anyone
refer to them as Dr Martens before it
doesn't make it wrong though it doesn't
make it wrong it doesn't but well anyway
clearly this resonated because uh Tick
Tock was buzzing Dr Martens the comments
were awesome by the way but Lena I've
never heard anyone call it Dr Martens
that is so formal not Martin's full
career name I love this one not his
government name
Dr Martin PhD she puts so much respect
on his PhD I'm not a doctor yeah awesome
but you see people are spelling it
m-a-r-t-e-n-s like that's how you say it
Martin oh that's how it's spelled though
too
oh it is well then I'm once again the
idiot
well congratulations you get a lot of
followers from that I did yeah my
account was finally growing again so I'm
excited congratulations thank you
is it true that AB masterminded that
AV claims he masterminded it
he had some involvement yeah he he saw
the potential
tell me what happened I want to be the
general okay she was watching it back
because she watches him back a million
times and uh I think it's my brother or
my cousin someone said like did you just
say Dr Martin and she's like oh yeah why
what's wrong with that and she's like oh
should I reshoot it I'm not gonna leave
it leave it because okay okay wow there
it is a b yeah The Mastermind
thank you thank you genius
I wish you'd toss me some ideas like
that I try get me yeah you do try I'm
just kidding
you do try you're great
um let's see what else I've been going
hard on the Ethan Klein Channel during
the break
if you guys don't know this is my
special secret little commentary Channel
I don't really promote on it I just just
like straight [ __ ] posting
so [ __ ] posting actually to the point
where I realized I could record videos
on my phone and upload it on my phone
but they have to be one take so I
started doing that this is like the
ultimate shipment like is there more of
a YouTube ship I was like I don't think
anybody's doing that but me
recording on your phone and uploading it
on your phone I thought they were really
fun though which is kind of interesting
like you could make a video with
literally
nothing
going into the making of it just one
shot on your phone and that's awesome
because now and it was still good and
entertaining I love that thank you ELO
now put that phone down different
perspectives oh I didn't think about
that thank you Gary
um yeah but
now I feel like I can actually maintain
the shuttle because it's like Farm Fresh
you know they say Farm to mount what did
they say
full organic content it actually is more
ass to mouth than you said a [ __ ]
posting so you're kind of just [ __ ]
right in our mouths with them no but
this is this is Farm to Table content I
swear from the from the minute I push
the record button to the time you can
watch it it's like 15 minutes a good
family farms I don't make a thumbnail
either at Auto Select it's so crazy
yeah so
been having fun over there obviously
there's been so much that has happened
yes
and that always happens where we go on
break the craziest [ __ ] goes down man
it's happening it's happening
I think this was the first fit I made
was Andrew take goes got arrested that
was huge news
then James Charles got exposed really
funny he just just super cringy
uh DMs I don't know if y'all saw these
but they're actually pretty funny it's
worth showing you guys
um he's just he's just so pathetic dude
it's awesome
he's dming with this Scott straight guy
and he's trying to you know he's trying
to [ __ ] him uh he wants it sounds like
he wants a baby uh daddy or what do you
call it Sugar Sugar Daddy sugar boy he
wants a sugar baby lots of sugar baby
sugar baby boy he says he says do you
want to be my boyfriend it's a really
lucrative role it's called being my
boyfriend requirements six two plus
okay sure my take was like bro trust me
nobody wants to [ __ ] you already like
you're setting the bar too high like the
next two plus really
laughs
must love escape rooms and horror movies
and cuddling the joke I made that
everybody loved was in any room with you
is an escape room which is true
trust me just if being your boyfriend is
a horror movie Enough dude
let's just watch like wholesome [ __ ] big
dick
fair enough
that's what I thought
I'm just like what is this like hi he
has no game like he does not know how to
talk to people he is just I don't I
don't know man I I don't know I'm gonna
read this I'm gonna be like yes I'm
interested this is just the most turn
off I have no [ __ ] idea I genuinely
don't and I was trying to put myself in
the mind of like a single straight man
like would is this an interesting offer
let's say you're in Kansas and your life
isn't going anywhere and he's like come
to La I'll you know I'll blow you you
can f me in the a notch and I'll you can
live rent free
it literally seems like bait for cloud
Chasers like those are questions that
only Cloud Chasers would respond but
he's down as long as you know no that's
what he's yeah he's trying to do oh I
didn't even acknowledge how I look by
the way oh my God it by the way let's
acknowledge how great ELO looks God damn
Alphas are fuming about how ugly you are
right now I know sorry I apologize you
look awesome show me your dress I
thought that was so cool your outfit it
is a cool dress
work it work it
yes yes yes yes
um I sent her Instagram post too if
you're my friend life for shopping on
Instagram she makes this dresses from
like vintage t-shirts oh is that like an
upcycle yeah oh fun really cool
and then um I also was wearing this damn
jacket that I'm just so happy with what
how it came out it's coming out soon oh
that's a Teddy fresh beef yeah it looks
so vintage I know
I know so this is like a very classic
vintage jacket and I really wanted to
recreate that and make it tasty fresh
nice you did it man so happy how it
turned out with the cute lining
also this bag is out now which is super
killer super nice
um
here it is
so tell me about this bag it's got like
a it's also kind of vintage inspired
from kind of finish and then what do you
call this I like this this fabric but I
don't know what it's called just p u p u
p u
H
still got it you still got it got it
Best comedian in the game thank you guys
yeah it's um it's got this you know
plaid and then we have the little teddy
fries the purple I love that
actually uh just super cute quickly a
new drop actually just came out a couple
days ago really nice oh the Ted we made
a teddy bear it sold out immediately
um that was really fun to see we're
gonna keep making teddy bear teddy fresh
teddy bears with different outfits and
we'll keep reissuing them but we'll
never repeat so you gotta get it when it
drops because we'll never make it again
oh [ __ ] looks great yeah it looks
awesome it's a great new technology
oh the earrings sold out too that's
awesome
[Applause]
yeah so the teddy bear said sorry will
not be back
um next year maybe around December we'll
release a new one and I want to make him
like a new outfit every time we're gonna
do a new one maybe once or twice a year
and a new outfit every time it's gonna
be awesome it's gonna be so fun now this
hoodie is super simple but to me it's
like one of my favorite pieces ever it's
just a really nice pet is this the
rubber patch yeah
but the the fit and the fabric is just
phenomenal it's just a really really
capsule of Basics was um just a small
smaller little update but um all of them
have a bear
made of rubber so like the T-shirt yeah
for example over there this one's rubber
yeah it's the bear patches rubber bear
patch
oh that looks clean yeah but all these
ones are like super perfected you know
like the fit the fabric everything is
just super good whoa what's this what's
that star
it's made in USA completely oh yeah
oh
[Applause]
it's been celebrating Christmas in July
mom and dad an apple pie
CE
of my life that's America
shooting schools
we gotta re do that one man America's
changed I'm so excited that we're
finally in the year of 2023 because like
we work a year in advance so
I pretty much have this whole year
already designed it's already
every month release is already designed
and I know it's coming I'm not going to
tell you the whole year yeah wow but
there's some cool stuff actually um
January is really small compared but
then um it's gonna get pretty spicy
later in the year This was um one of my
uh designs that uh was restocked you
should always be your biggest Advocate
it's been a difficult year and you
should be proud of yourself for pushing
through make sure to set time aside for
yourself so you can focus on your mental
health and self-improvement if you don't
have your health you don't have anything
[ __ ]
I should just I think they should make
more shirts like this with like the yeah
those are my favorite hardcore
inspirational the pack
yeah so that one's back in stock and
there was another and out of your league
yeah this is fun dedicated to all my
Fanboys out there
you know like Andrew Tate or so good
Jeffrey Dahmer's yeah did it make the
shirt because over the break everyone
kept calling oh yeah Aiden Ross
um which we'll talk about he I mean
we're gonna be besties already but yeah
no I know it's still out of your league
I know I'm not ready to adopt him but
anyway at the time we met that he called
him like ugly and could call me fat and
her ugly yeah
um and like it's just so funny how they
always do that so Ela had this great
idea to make the shirt out of your
league
and I think it's I think it's fantastic
so anyway that's what's going on there
oh and then um over the break also Teddy
fresh released in Urban Outfitters which
was a really big thing that was uh your
that was like your dream partner right
yeah for the longest time because I
personally discovered so many Brands
through shopping on Urban and
from the moment I moved to America and
or even visited here the first store I
think we went to in a mall was Urban and
I was like oh my God this is such a cool
store
so it's yeah it's definitely been a
dream of mine for a long time I don't
think they're in stores yet it's not
because it happened they started out
with really small test orders and they
were gonna go into stores but it's
already selling like online most of it
so they got like really small like 30
items like yeah very small amount it's
just that's how it was with Zoomies
where they they're like I was like okay
so people want to buy this [ __ ] and then
they start ordering more so I think
it'll be in stores lit by later this
year
that's exciting you know we left Zumiez
because we wanted to be in a
kind of more classy store I guess if
that's the word classy I don't know not
really it's just I think it's more
fashionable I think it's a tiny bit more
elevated yes and I think the demographic
is a tiny bit older and more I think
it's just like a wider range so
yeah well congrats that's huge news I
know you've been super excited about
that by the way thank you Madison
for a big old Dono I submitted a
portfolio to the TF careers email okay
okay I love you could take a look okay
awesome thank you God bless thank you
hello you're gonna need a job after you
keep making donations that big
you know what I mean
but anyway back to James Charles who uh
yeah that's awesome
yeah so he needs he says he's a big dick
and also armpit hair which we know is
his MO
do you think he rubs his dick in the
armpit hair or does sexual what is the
deal with the armpit hair
it's very masculine and maybe I mean
well women have armpit hair but he loves
it you think he smells it and stuff and
like rubs on it
ah stiffy loves it that much
braid it he probably licks it
probably loves probably he probably does
he probably does something with it
wait people are asking about the Elon
shirt what does that mean when does this
ship it's shipping this month oh yes
it's so yeah that was a pre-order there
was a bunch of them and we had to wait
basically they were being made but I
believe that this month is actually
doing its shipping so it should be keep
to you today yeah you guys are gonna get
them soon promise
um it's yeah
yeah it's on schedule I knew it was
going to take a while
um
do you think that he
do you think that he flosses with armpit
hair
oh my God
there's no possibility he must do it all
I think he would make his guy like go
for a really long run and then come back
and take a steep Sniff and maybe and
maybe run his balls through it
foreign
[Music]
some people like the Natural Body smell
and it creases sexual attraction for
them he just likes is it the smell yeah
let's get Glam do they do anything with
the hair I have a nice
smelly man I just don't know why do you
need to say it like if you're trying to
hit on somebody why does that need to be
in your opening lines yeah like
everybody has armpit hair something you
shave it I guess okay so they can not
you like let's get past a few steps here
in the relationship too much and then
you can say do you mind not shaving it
or something well also big dick is
pretty like yeah maybe let's introduce
ourselves yeah yes flavors
flavors what about a medium dick
I don't think James will take it no he
wants a hog
a hairy hog
an occasional FaceTime call well that's
not bad this salary is zero bruh he says
but it's a good job offer and he because
I guess the job offer is you get to live
in a mansion He says perks include a
cute boyfriend I'll be debatable with a
great personality debatable huge ass
that's true he's got the fact yeah free
living in a 10 million dollar house in
LA
fun travel opportunities good head and
more
pretty well I mean this this is the
package deal it's a funny man hey he
these it's just people always [ __ ]
leak his texts and he keeps saying [ __ ]
like this it's just incredible it's
awesome so that is
love it that is the most notable part of
this to me isn't it yeah how is that you
guys doing you can just let it slide
please you ready for my first theory of
the year go ahead yeah I know he does it
on purpose oh he's a way for him to send
out a message to anyone who's interested
he knows people are going to leak it and
hopefully Whoever has fits the role will
reach out it'll go viral and then
somebody will see it yeah
super horny I think he's 5D chessing his
oh for sure DM me I don't think he's
willing to embarrass himself that much I
don't know I mean he has to realize that
they're gonna be out there at this point
it's happened 30 times but do people
realize that
and that is a question for in regards to
all the bad news that's been happening
all right yeah that's a good point
um though I'm sure we'll get to later
maybe you always have the [ __ ]
wildest like angles on [ __ ] yeah but
they end up being right A lot of times
give me some credit
some of the time I don't know some of
the time what's one that okay all right
you know you're right all you're right
Ace Fest what was your theory about
acefit you guys thought it wasn't gonna
happen or it's gonna be a [ __ ] showdowns
like it's probably gonna happen and be a
lot of fun well that that's not a crazy
Theory I mean it was a 50 50 going to
pause
now you're right you are right you're
smart you're right with Lena
yeah
you know what I mean
people are really saying King shaming
come on it's James Charles it's all fair
game I'm not King shaming at all if you
want to rub your balls through some
dude's [ __ ] armpit hair I'm not
saying that you shouldn't I'm just
saying
like don't put that [ __ ] kink in your
like intro message and those balls
should be over 18.
um
some old balls stick to old balls those
balls need to be 18. what's your balls
prehistoric balls they were actually 16.
oh oh no that is not good
not good come on how do you come back
from that I'm just I'm not surprised
that he hasn't found anyone like
well he's looking for straight men so
that's hard that's a problem that's
probably a hurdle and I can just say
like but with messages like that it's
like I don't know up your game a little
I guess he's not wasting time can he
probably copy paste that to a hell of
dudes but what's the game a surface
level connection I feel like it that's a
hookup invite that's not a boyfriend
invite right no it's like he's looking
for a sex slave he wants yeah he's just
looking for like a sex companion yeah
does someone hook up with and only only
be his
I think he thinks that Jeffree Star did
that I think like his boyfriend I think
was straight or came out that like he
was just like a sex slave for Jeffrey
and he was I don't know that yeah he had
this book yeah I know I know it's crazy
I think I mean I could be speaking at a
turn but I'm pretty sure that happened
I know that he was straight before he
dated Jeffrey yeah I think it was
straight afterwards
but anyway there was that this was a
crazy story man with uh
what's his name Kai Kai Central High
Centra it's nuts it ain't I mean Nissan
Sentra wait I know that's not right okay
Central for a while
starting off you're strong people
Kai Kai Central Kia Centro wait no now
I'm confused
the net
I'm not even gonna get super into this
but he's like the biggest streamer he's
like the big he's like the biggest
growing influencer right now yeah and
one of his homies apparently like
violently R worded a girl who's at the
party and it was just oh my God a crazy
mess man really sad what can I interrupt
for just a second go ahead
we still haven't talked about why you
look like a burn victim yeah
it's true I do look like that it's just
High fashion all right you guys want to
know so well it's specifically The Coop
that he has on his face dude
so what happened was that um I everyone
loved the bleached hair so I we got our
hair cut yesterday and it'll bleached
your hair and I said I'll bleach my hair
cool it was fun and then at the last
minute I was like
let's go for you know let's
doesn't know [ __ ] about false ending
right I'm gonna send it that's facts
you're not sending [ __ ] okay I full stop
the half centers over there I sat down
and I said let's full send let's bleach
my whole [ __ ] beard my mustache and
my eyebrows
and I was like why like you do you know
that if you just do your hair you're
gonna look really good
that was the problem and it's like he
doesn't want to look good like I want to
make you happy
this is like a dip issue here that we
could talk about and unpack I think I do
understand it like on a deep
psychological issue I think it's that
you're allowed to look good
if you want to know my actual theory on
it
is that um
I I don't want not I don't want to put
down my dad but it's related to him dad
I love you but you know like just sorry
but my dad was such a kind of perv
growing up
and it was a full art the flirtiness and
stuff it was just always I just always
was so disgusted and hated it so much
smash that like button and I think I in
a way make myself as gross looking as
possible so that like
[Music]
nobody's attracted to me I don't know
and then like
I don't know what it is I think it's
time does that make sense yes it's time
to break that
and break the cycle I don't want people
to be attracted to me I don't want
people to flirt with me I just want to
be a monogamous
for life
you get all this girl
just you you know it's fine with me but
like that's why it's great that's why
we're perfect but I don't think that
anything's gonna change who you are you
are
who you are but I think you're
regardless I think it's fun it's funny
it is fun and fun it's like there's
different eras I just really saw it
yesterday it's like it's like one moment
before doing something that you know is
just purely for Aesthetics you're like
no I gotta make this funny I'm not gonna
do something just and it's not funny
yeah ninja done kind of funny
I wonder how the break was for ninja and
also David
oh God what is David up to oh God I see
listen for this show what's gonna be
more funny if I show up with bleached
hair if I show up like a [ __ ] albino
and
um and it's gonna be fun and it'll be
like a fun month where I look crazy you
know it's it's nice it's like a
timepiece time period everybody loves it
whatever you whatever makes you feel
better thank you I just want you to feel
good about yourself
thank you you've been looking really
good lately I think like really I'm back
showing everything that you're doing
it's really showing
oh thank you so much I'm back going
hardcore since we got back from vacation
with my dieting
we've had someone in our basement my
friend my friend Sean was fitting so
he's in the basement sleeping there and
so now that he's gone I'll get back on
the treadmill and keep going hard again
[ __ ] my basement I don't well
there's a bathroom down there so
is that okay if I [ __ ] down there Jeremy
in the back the toilet peed in my
basement
people pointed out that the Ethan Klein
Channel you really see the difference
from yeah the newest videos look dude I
noticed that too man like look at this
one yeah that yeah
bro I look like a hog here no offense to
the fatties in the chat I'm just talking
about myself
uh
yeah yeah it's crazy so I'm gonna keep
going you know I'm on my fitness journey
my fitness journey flavors
all different flavors
yeah but um what were we talking about
we were talking oh David dobrik's dating
Dixie that's weird because she was that
confirmed I don't think I think it's
based off of just one Snapchat yeah
someone said they're on a date she like
kept buying a cute photo with him like
on a date well news though listen if uh
David needs a bowl
I know a guy
Brad mm-hmm
because he likes to watch David likes to
watch
um did you cut her hair short
it's great like that yeah yeah she's
very pretty the both yeah they're
they're beautiful David and Vicki
Beauties yeah
anyways uh we're at break time anyway so
we gotta do our ads okay I was saying
that I bleached the face bleaching she
that she hadn't really done it before
she did it once but it was really short
so it was really hot I put all the
bleach on my face and under my nose and
I thought I was getting brain damage I
was like bro every second is shaving a
minute off my life for sure I was
standing under the fan you know how in
the kitchen oven there's like an exhaust
that stuff there blows it outside so I
put that on I was saying there but it
was still too strong he opened the doors
to get air in and then it was like how
can I breathe but not smell this and
we're like maybe a straw I had to
breathe the air over here this was all
contaminated it was right in my [ __ ]
nose
and they've got him in this like turkey
paste thing turkey baster without the
pumping part and he was trying to
breathe through that quick thinking but
yeah my face started burning and you can
see now why it looks like I just came
back from a burn victim unit because I
had to cover my face in Vaseline because
it's so [ __ ] up so I'm looking super
shiny and as you can tell it was a huge
success definitely worth it yeah I'll be
honest I wanted a full send it so hard I
asked if I could bleach my [ __ ]
eyelashes he really did ask that and
we're like
you don't want that on your eye
yeah I realized that was probably poor
Jess I feel like afterwards she was like
a little bit traumatized you think so
it's possible it wasn't pretty going
full Jay Leno huh
what the burning yeah I'm trying man
he's my idol trying to burn myself
trying to flip a car yeah
all right let's thank our sponsors and
we got a lot more show left
thank you so much to our beautiful
sponsors today I don't have access
to the copy
love that to either of them love that
uh you're not logged in on that laptop
I am logged
and to I mean I'm in the dock so I am
logged in okay
give me a second Bam Bam for a second
you're signed in it yeah yeah I'm logged
in
request sent
yes
yes yes yes thank you to our sponsors we
love them folks whoever they are
great people
I'm sure that whatever product they have
is the best in category
I'm still signed into my dad's fake
email that he did with Jimmy Lee
matter ex-gare bear69x gmail.com this is
the email we made him to sign in Old Man
test
all right try the top one now you should
be okay alrighty
you need access
let's go
yes metal oh okay I got the access to
one of them here we go thank you to a
honey wow
today's episode is sponsored by Honey
the easy way to save When shopping on
your iPhone or computer
man boy do I love honey if you are
shopping online on your phone or
computer and you don't have the honey
plugin you are taking fat elves
because what honey does is that checkout
it automatically score score scours the
internet
for the best coupon code available and
automatically applies it there's no cash
there's no strings it's just good good
good stuff man and we've saved so much
money just passively shopping that we
would have never got I mean here's one
from
I don't know a company that is the Z but
save 10 bucks on a 45 purchase it's
crazy it's food yeah computers Furniture
clothing gadgets clothing
every every online retailer basically
this is going to work for if they have
any codes available and a lot of them do
um it's free
to install
all you got to do is uh click a honey
button will appear and all you have to
do is Click apply coupon boom bam bada
bing bada boom honey doesn't just work
on desktops it's also on your iPhone now
too just activate it on Safari on your
phone and save on the go that's great
for a long time it was just desktop
you don't really have honey
you are going to be straight up missing
out and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself assault and supporting the show
thank you so much get PayPal honey for
free at joinhoney.com
h3tv that's joinhoney.com h3tv I do love
honey and thank you to our wonderful
sponsors thank you thank you honey honey
yes
and we have one more here do I have
access yes I do
oh God do I love them it's stabs.com
let's go yo stamps.com is legit changing
the game
first of all
we all got stuff to mail holidays come
maybe you have a small business we all
got stuff to mail and if you're doing it
the old-fashioned way you're not doing
it right
okay
stamps.com is teamed up with the post
office to give you huge discounts on
mailing and shipping up to 86 percent
off
you freaking kidding me you don't have
to think about it dude it's like the
post office but Elevate at stamps.com
has an amazing partnership with them as
I said 86 off samsung.com automatically
tells you what's the cheapest and
fastest shipping option right from your
computer there's no guessing there's no
overpaying there's no thinking required
what I love about stamps excuse me
is that you get a digital scale
you weigh it at home and then you print
out the highly discounted
um postage the perfect amount you tape
it on your package and then here's the
best part they come get it or you put it
or you just drop it off or you drop it
in a Dropbox time efficiency dude
it's cheaper it's more convenient I mean
and your your girlfriend or was used has
been using stamps right Dan Ali loves it
she's been using it for years to as a
basis for all of her shipments for her
online business and it could not be
easier I just uh
drops them off at the post office for
her the other day as a matter of what a
guy what a guy what a guy we got here
and Dan easy
yeah
it's awesome so give it a shot and
support the show get a four week trial
free postage and a digital skill at
stamps.com
h3tv thanks to stamps.com for sponsoring
the show we love them thank you guys
thank you everybody okay
it's stamps.com
let's put a stamp on it
and mail it to my friend okay
it's stamps.com
yeah uh let's see what else oh here's
some other big news yeah Ian who won Mr
verify long time ago he won he won the
privilege of rewriting an email to
Instagram asking
no it was for Instagram wasn't it oh
they wanted insta okay they can buy I
mean I already bought bro I you better
cancel that membership on paper Ian is
that paying like 12 bucks a month for he
has to be verified on Twitter
I I don't I don't really remember I
don't know
dude
he got verified on Instagram and I'm
saying my part's been fulfilled bro
you did it son of a [ __ ] did it and
it's full I take full credit even though
the email I sent to my Instagram rep was
unanswered right I think he took him
like over you put the wheels checked her
inbox afterwards dude I put the wheels
in motion I think I also asked my
network I said yo we got to get this guy
verified anything you think you also
asked your network or did you ask not
100 I don't think not 100 sure actually
but I'll take credit for it um but here
let me open it up so congratulations Ian
that's pretty exciting what do you think
exciting this is awesome man beautiful
and so
um
he is Mr verified those cheeks look at
that check mark baby
existence is validated fine right you
exist we weren't sure before but now we
know I think he is Mr verified beautiful
and Charming blue checks everywhere
it's sort of yes
uh blue checks everywhere
Mr verified what is it you're really
getting your moment to shine here yeah
go ahead I'm not gonna interrupt you I'm
just I think I think what pushed it over
the edge was Kanye kind of had to be a
sacrificial lamb I it was like a Obi-Wan
Anakin I had to I had to stab him in the
back a little bit for those articles
that got me the check so unfortunately
Connie had to fall oh [ __ ] so let me ask
you this did it just happen randomly or
did you present it
uh I I submitted it a few days ago with
the Kanye article that's pretty baller
it did it within a day wow okay can I
say something like those articles the
modding thing I mean listen that all
doesn't exist without me so I mean let's
just be real I got you verified
all the time
while you're at it
but congratulations that's awesome thank
you I'm so glad you got verified
thank you thank you it sounds like y'all
could try for it too but you just gotta
hustle with all and love you got like a
billion articles about you now love no
yeah oh yeah I've been hustling over the
bridge I've got like 10 articles
love has been doing some crazy
groundwork together it's awesome yeah I
was telling him before the show started
I could already see him with his cowboy
hat and giant belt buckle he's gonna be
here boy get in some Sarsaparilla yeah
I've been I've been really juicing and
juicing the Articles it's been fun too
you're getting more interviews and stuff
yeah dude you're gonna get here I'm sure
of it I'm opening so yeah actually it's
kind of funny or not it's not really
funny but to help um love out
I've been helping him get
letters of uh
endorsement how would you call it love
Yeah like your recommendation letters
from people I've worked with uh
noteworthy people and so I was getting
ready to uh have uh Justin royland sign
one for him
do you I'm I'm guessing you don't want
that one
you still want that one love
uh we're throwing that one out I think I
was kind of joking I was like yo I got
all I got a bunch of recommendations for
you lineup I got Andrew Callahan
uh Chris Delia right right right who
else do we have when we get one Shane
Dawson Shane Dawson I can probably good
friend of the show how about this like
if if this round doesn't get uh like
accepted and I get a little bit uh you
know
down bad I'm gonna go for them
I could probably write Harvey Weinstein
in prison he has a lot of free time
maybe he'll endorse you because he says
a lot of free time
yeah you want to look at some of these
articles though they're pretty badass
this one is actually secret Los Angeles
I think this is like a big Vlog I've
heard of this one before they're massive
massive videos how did you set this up
well it's all like uh people who just
reached out to me after we talked about
them yes so Sophie Lynn a shout the [ __ ]
out how's one of the first like q a
interviews secret La has ever done so
they took it yeah they took a massive
risk doing this so dude Sophie you rule
we love you you're a friend of the show
forever uh Queen Sophie over here but
check out the title
it's uh young how young how love AKA
young fika of H3 became an essential
part of one a one of LA's biggest
podcasts yo that headline is like
engineered for you yeah it didn't even
have it I that's all of them that's all
them I didn't oh yeah dude that's a
that's awesome that's the picture when
we we found out we were I was pregnant
with Bruce oh right yeah
right right right and now he's almost a
year old boy and he's a good he's just
awesome but here you are proof that you
actually do work with us
yeah look at this lots of q a so
congrats bro so cool we're gonna get you
out here this year yeah this year is the
Year this is the year of love
thank you guys thank you guys for the
opportunity massive I'm living my dream
guys I gotta I gotta say even even from
Sweden I'm living my dream and to come
to LA and work with you guys permanently
that's crazy that would be crazy we're
gonna make it happen bro
I'll put a word in
yeah I'll message immigration they
should see it you can run to the top you
know he's not wrong
um
can I just if you make it over here can
we bleach your hair and eyebrows and
beard
and mustache [ __ ] all of it yeah all of
it but not your not your eyelashes I'll
spare you that
oh that's so nice yeah
why not my man what are you gonna say no
to me uh no exactly what I've always
been kind of Die Hard I'm not never
probably gonna do that but [ __ ] it
actually you know what I don't wanna I
feel like maybe I'm coercing you because
I'm not gonna cancel your Visa if you
say no obviously yes but I will do it
for I'm all for the content anything for
the show okay
what about your armpit here for
treatment oh my God
okay I'll do that too maybe I'll let you
live yeah
yeah that's better than uh what's that
place called
kidro where you were living yeah
the peaceful Hotel
we were right up the street from it
actually oh God that place is so haunted
yep I don't believe in ghosts but I
ain't going anywhere near that [ __ ]
place yeah
um
the live show was awesome yeah it was so
much fun yeah it went great the audience
was super duper it was just an awesome
event you guys did an amazing job you
all put a lot of hard work thank you the
team was great and it was just like it
went off without a hedge it was just
super fun yep and awesome I think are we
in the talks to plan another one because
I'm I'm down I thought it was a good I
mean we were talking about it a little
bit right afterwards but then you know
we went on break so there hasn't really
been too much movement on it but now
that we're back yeah I mean we could
start playing in the next one why not
how many seats is that the ace 1500 or
so that one's about 15 yeah so that's
about double the size of the one that we
just so maybe we should do the ace next
maybe so because I know a lot of people
the thing is the Ace does get booked
pretty far in advance
um but we can still try
good try
but if not maybe we do that one later in
the year how many seats does the
Hollywood Bowl it's less than you think
it's actually only 5 000 right it's more
than that but it's it's not that big of
the venue Hollywood Bowl seats 10 000
DPI okay what the [ __ ] is that oh 17 000
hell no is that you when you were sick
okay that must be what it is what the
can you explain the lore on the Epi 800
wait you you don't remember
well now I do I didn't immediately you
were messaging me at like two in the
morning voice memos I'm like what the
[ __ ] I was super [ __ ] sick and zonked
out of my mind on cold medicine
well I appreciate the fact that you did
do that his voice was legit like the DPI
guy 600 DPI
run me through it
1500 DPI 1200 DPI it sounds like a DP uh
600 DPR sorry guys this is the new DPI
DPI
800 800 DPI 800 DPI 800 DPI 800 dtdi oh
my God yeah so after the live show
unfortunately I did the show sick I had
a fever
I thought I was getting better I think
what happened was I got a bacterial
infection from the live show from
talking and screaming and [ __ ] and then
I got like even more sick
so to go the
um I had to go to the doctor and get
some flavors flavors that's some
antibiotics
it took me a while to get better
honestly my throat is still kind of
effed up it's crazy I'm still coughing
from it yeah but um yeah I was super
sick but and whatever
I'm good now it was worth it it's fun
I'm glad we did it
creep shot of Dan yeah I was gonna say
yeah everyone did really good it was
really awesome to be part of that but I
was really just amazed by Dan like
running different Crews and just very
professional I was like oh I was in awe
and I just kind of took a picture they
gave me like
but yeah he's in his element he was in
his Element no it was it was awesome
very it was kind of cool to be back
because for those that
Jesus
for those that aren't aware before I
came and worked on the podcast I did
live shows at venues like that uh as a
career for many years and so that was
sort of like a you know throwback for me
to be in that environment at a venue and
doing all that kind of stuff um and it
was fun but it was also a reminder that
I I
much much prefer doing what we do here
in the studio and I'm so grateful for
this job and uh well we love it it was a
really stressful job right yeah it's
extremely stressful because you know the
the timelines on everything is very
short and you're basically walking into
a new building uh every day and building
a studio yeah and then tearing it down
at the end of the night and uh you know
and trying to get it all working and
fixed and everything so anyway was it
like a feast and famine thing where
sometimes you didn't have work oh yeah
big time see that that sucks yeah that
was part of why I was very happy to jump
ship and come work for you guys because
you guys just offered me a freaking
salary which that was like I I was a gig
worker for a decade prior right so well
it's pretty nice you're the man well we
were looking for a producer and then
we're like he seems good let's just try
it let's offer dance
wait wait wait why did I say you were
sending back voice memos
I do not run
it was seriously yeah two or three in
the morning and I was like deep into
NyQuil wait why does would you have that
back
you tell me dude
I'm doing my job here wait wait wait
wait wait what else did I send you it
was just all like different number dpis
and then just dance words
that's so funny just Dan that's it oh my
God
what the hell
oh it's funny
oh yeah somebody's gave us this at the
live show isn't this awesome
prolapse Vision
I love it looking out nope this is like
everybody looks into the prolapse but
what if I told you people look out of
the prologue right what do we do about
it in the Matrix bro what do we do about
it yeah
this is the year of I think hopefully
moving past the prolapse right yeah yeah
no no no we need a new sort of horrific
bodily function to embrace this year
we'll find her lapses are played out
well we'll find it I'm sure maybe
hemorrhoids or something or like oh
you've heard this thing called um
what is it called when they put [ __ ] in
the dig hole it's so funny but some
people oh wait it's called a sounding
yes yes
and I don't know how they like it so
they put [ __ ] in their dick hole as to
gratify themselves
that is worse how can that be because
like putting a catheter as I understand
it's like the most painful thing I think
it's very painful but I don't know they
love it so do they do they love getting
a catheter I wonder if they're like this
is my [ __ ] let's go I'm not taking a
pause to pee why do you guys know oh
I don't know honestly well the thing
about sounding is you see it once and
you never forget it yeah I don't think
I've actually seen it I've just I've
seen it okay well I just saw it oh you
looked it up yeah describe it describe
what you're seeing or they're shopping I
always look to see if Olivia's looking
at my screen
you don't have to look you don't have to
look a little yeah no someone got to
look at it with me I am okay
that seems that's irrelevant no because
it's a smaller hole oh
what okay oh my God oh my God so maybe
sounding is the new thing
that's what I'm thinking
I think they work it and the more you do
it the bigger the hole gets let me turn
my monitor for a sec
um no I don't want to no you don't want
to I just want to know what you're
seeing Oh my God okay his thing is this
small that this catheters oh it's a
catheter I don't know I think it's
called a sounding Rod dark magic there's
like a lot of resistance like a dancing
Rod sounding Rod don't you dare are you
puking don't you dare it's not even that
bro oh we are off to a great start here
baby you better hurry baby
all right that's just silly bro by the
end of the year maybe I mean this is
disgusting I'm still watching it take it
off turn it off stop it putting [ __ ] in
his penis what do you mean it's not that
bad
Jessica jingle says I've sounded a guy
before
what and by the way no hate soundlessly
if you're into it there's nothing wrong
just like the prolapsing I respect and I
might be something wrong with that one
for me like all I can think of sorry but
it is before I give birth when Theodore
and they gave me epidural and then they
or they did the catheter and then the
epidural oh no and that's the wrong
order exactly and I didn't know I didn't
even know that that was a thing
everybody always like you always worry
about that shot in the back of the
epidural you hear about that one a lot
and that wasn't as bad the catheter was
the worst part why didn't they give you
the numbing first what the [ __ ] that's a
good question why the hell would they do
that first I don't know
no I don't know
yeah so anyway we're a sounding family
now
someone in the chat said they also call
it [ __ ] stuffing which is a much more
straightforward name I gotta say the
sounding is a little deceptive of how
horrible it really is Cox always
sounding related like sound I don't I
have no idea why it's called scream at
the top here alone yeah I think that's
why I remembered it because it's like
such a weird name yeah so graphic but
yeah I mean listen if you're into
sounding God bless and I feel like maybe
we should even find the sounding King
much like we did with Hunger FF get
Howie out here I can't follow you down
this road man I will follow you okay
we'll follow you down this road my
friend what happens when the sounding
King meets the prolapse King
that's some I don't think they're
compatible because they're they're kind
of into they're kind of opposites in a
way but that's a paradox so a sounding
Rod it is called a sounding wrong it is
a rod that is used to measure the depth
of water under a boat or in a ship's
hole or other container so it's a
sounding Rod so a [ __ ] a dude in the
Navy started this [ __ ] yeah something in
the Navy shoving [ __ ] up his nickel you
get bored out there it's a sounding rod
it's like sounding
also um
I thought we weren't gonna top last
year's prolapse and here we go well we
had to transition so we're into sounding
now it's like a dick prolapse if you
kind of really want to think about it
this is the year of sounding
what's that
it sounds that sound
I can hear it
well there it is yeah that's exactly
that's the sound of 2023
yeah if people didn't do it for fun I'd
be I would think for sure that was a
form of torture
you know
but um also I want to thank the members
y'all really
a lot of the members just came along
actually we got a lot of new members
because I was kept doing the Tuesday
episodes over the break we had some
awesome lives I was just doing lives
like it is now talking with the chat
talking about stuff it was super fun and
just thank you to all the members who
were hanging out and um and uh thank you
who became members over the break that
was awesome super awesome super nice so
thank you guys
name of the gifted bloody Rivers what
have you been sounding
his name's bloody Rivers thank you
yeah
um
the Troubadour happened yeah the big day
happened
[Applause]
with Zach uh we're doing it again at the
Roxy in May so wait how many seats does
Roxy it's the same number about the same
size 500 yeah so Roxy in May yeah start
early let's get it going when those
tickets go up tickets are gonna go out
uh probably uh mid-February for that get
those tickets up yeah but that was A
Night at the Roxbury yeah exactly but it
was it was truly a wonderful experience
and I want to thank everyone that came
out here let me pull up some of the
videos
it was awesome actually it looked like a
rock I mean you are a rockstar thank you
this was my favorite uh one he's done so
far super good stage presents too thank
you here it is let's see here's Zaki
crushing it look at this
[Applause]
you're not gonna claim me are you no
this isn't like copyright music this is
me though you're not gonna claim it no
this is not it's not a song
[Applause]
Troubadour was never the same again
thank you
got that whammy paddle a whammy pedal
paddle wow pedal
[Music]
oh God bro no he's got you better light
that guitar on fire
[Music]
he was throwing picks out you were yeah
picks out to the crowd walking fight
over him and [ __ ] dude that's awesome
you show your dick or buy eat a small
animal or anything no but people kept
asking me to show prolapse on stage
yo that's never been done not even by
like GG Allen [ __ ] you know
um but yeah it was it was wild and my
bandmates they were like you know what
you need to go down first and just go
[ __ ] shred because oh that's cool
yeah and I love my phone it is the Zack
I mean it is the Zach Lewis experience
that's gonna be real I want to give a
shout out to my other bandmates other
Zach my bass player Zach who have known
10 years and then Sage uh those guys are
they're [ __ ] solid there's like Gabe
at the Troubadour so my dad was like in
the pit he was moshing and he sees Gabe
and he like pushes him up on stage your
dad yeah
there was a pick on for a little while
it was pretty wild your dad punching kid
like no no no no [ __ ] slam Dance Slam
Dancing and like he's like some dude
spilled her drink on me I don't give a
[ __ ] like yeah dude he was having a time
of his life yeah he was having a good
time Todd and talk
here it is here's White Club Gabe on
stage oh yeah
hell yeah
I'm man he you know what and even after
you you devastatingly blew him off on
his birthday he still came out for you
that's that's love right there for he's
a pleasure shout out to Nick Nick and
Gabe they're uh they're Legends yeah
they came out to the show too they were
great guys we're hanging out backstage
with them great guys man those two true
true dudes
has Ethan's shirt released this is ultra
right about a while ago I don't think
there's any more of it yeah oh we got a
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
dude I dude that's awesome he went up
there unplanned and just started working
the crowd yeah no he's he's the man he's
absolutely so [ __ ] funny yeah what a
night yeah that was [ __ ] here's a
video of the uh here's a video of the
the mosh here I got it and let's go
oh we got some hardcore
pooper Troopers
[Music]
there's Zach's dad yeah somewhere
stomping on some 20 year old hundreds
but who fell
they're trying to stand up he keeps
pushing him down
but yeah it was it was a great night and
um it felt like a dream being up there I
see people still asking where's my Elon
shirt it's coming it was definitely it's
on schedule it was going to take a while
but I think it should ship very soon
yeah this month like maybe by next well
I don't know for next episode maybe we
can give you the more update yeah
yeah excuse me so
so much popping man
um Sam bought a car in Georgia okay so
she's she's driving it
yeah she's uh that's why Sam isn't here
today she is uh coming back cross
country I hope that she doesn't have
Ian's luck with cars
does that thing I make him nobody has
the ends like with cars but I think
Ian's been through like three cars since
his tenure here at the podcast is that
right your new car is all groovy though
right you haven't had any problems so
far you got a new it's new yeah it's
like new new you're good if something
happens to that I'm I'm taking the bus
from now on I mean you're gonna have uh
some warranties and [ __ ] too yeah
but uh yes Sam uh she she got a Subaru
good guard about the Jeep she called she
she went test drove a bunch of uh Jeeps
yeah
she wasn't feeling it she uh she was she
was trying to find one that was a good
fit and then she just called me one day
and she was like I just drove the Subaru
and I I love this car the Subarus are
really good cars they apparently like
are built to last I love the car that
she got oh really yeah one of my best
friends had that same car for years and
it was like our Workhorse car for
everything basically and everything is a
beast wait pull it up she said it's a
2023 Subaru Outback I want to see what
that looks like here's what she said
bought my first new car
I know a lot of y'all were expecting a
Jeep I ended up getting a 2023 Subaru
Outback more practical car and I
absolutely love and I'm so thankful for
y'all
won't be on the show oh dude
it's more I don't think it's a full-size
SUV because I don't think it's based on
a truck body I think it's more like a
station wagon essentially watching make
sure you got the one on the uh the top
left like the all black I think yeah
yeah it looks just like this nice watch
this is gonna be posted on the server
people being like Sam needs to give that
money back she did not buy a Jeep for a
gym I'm I'm fuming all different flavors
yeah I know she was that looks kind of
stressed about about that but you know
listen
I mean the car's a car is it does it
actually matter no no people wanted to
help her buy a car yeah and it happened
keep your hands off my [ __ ] car
I I love this car I think she made a
good car yeah no it's really nice the
interior is really nice too has a really
big screen in the middle nothing like
getting a new car I tell you it's really
really a nice Sam just popped into her
oh Sam's internal cowboy hats said
Subaru Outback Wilderness oh oh well
which one's that I want to see that one
the Wilderness it's just like you going
off-roading special edition I love all
the pictures of it like off-road it's
like there ain't no way that car is
going off-road
although the uh freeways of Los Angeles
that's pretty off-road no it's like
all-wheel driving everything it can't
yeah this is the car
in Tahoe do that bottom left one of it
like
okay what's happening here it's
wilderness
get some mud treatment yeah oh hell yeah
brother we took this Subaru Outback
Outback is Outback got her stuck in the
mud
she did real good out there boy I got
her nice and muddy just like my poop
after a long night of drinking
flavors different flavors somebody Tyler
says Subaru is a great off-road I take
my uh XV I'm assuming all right I stand
for it all the time so there you go yeah
congratulations Sam
yeah brother Samantha she doesn't like
when I color that
that's what her mom calls her right now
who's Sam
um what else oh dude another crazy thing
that happened during the live show was I
got unbanned on Twitter during the live
it was so crazy so awesome
uh yeah
so we love Elon We Stand Elon in this
house he's a great guy
no
I thought this was like the bit that you
always do whenever somebody does
something nice for you nice yeah you
still hate him okay wow we're not dogs
he's such a douche such a [ __ ] douche
but I'm back on Twitter so [ __ ] it
never forget though and uh
don't call me don't say I'm body Shaman
he's Elon Musk he's the richest guy in
the world
weird body on yeah
and guys please please
because I don't think anyone has a body
like this so please if you have a body
like this you're beautiful but he is not
looking good what is happening what the
[ __ ] is that
explain that to me I don't I don't have
an explanation I saw I saw someone do a
drawing where it's like there's a little
person inside of a robot that's fine
he has like a metal mechanism oh like
the ribs should be like the little tiny
alien in uh Men In Black yeah yeah
piloting like a bigger guy he's getting
[ __ ] hosed down like cattle
yeah
that's it but obviously you know he's
done much worse things than have a weird
body
so we love Elon for that don't we folks
he's probably doing some kind of weird
like hormone duh [ __ ] stem cell
therapy that makes his gut
but it should or just steroids right
doesn't that kind of do that but he but
he was kind of jacked for a little while
I remember like a few years ago when he
was like
I love this
you like this is that awesome yeah this
makes more sense this works this works
for me
there you go Elon Musk everybody uh he's
still out there
doing his thing Elon Musk model X yeah
yo he literally looks like this
his body is this [ __ ] crazy
who drew this that's a kind of go ahead
cam you probably know more about it than
me but he's just a notoriously bad comic
artist from the 90s yeah oh and this is
not meant to be a joke this guy is like
kind of iconic yeah for how bad is that
for like how yeah wait is this like
Canon was this in an official yeah no no
no he worked for Marvel uh and he was a
very prolific comic book artist and like
the late 80s and 90s his drawings it's
good it's just weird Choice yeah it's
just so weird
insane is like legit Rob liefeld is his
name if you look at like Rob blindfold
Anatomy a bunch of [ __ ] oh I want to
see more from him
dude it's awesome because women were
similarly uh
insane looking like look at that spine
oh yeah oh there's fine why is it so art
holy [ __ ] yeah that's pretty wild
this is so funny yeah
this guy's awesome
well I've been going on what the hell
dude nobody looked at that and be like
dude there's something wrong with this
panel I mean it's it's as heavily styled
exaggerated exactly but it's just some
of it's pretty [ __ ] take it too far
Elon proves it's realistic now so yeah
it wasn't that enough there you go good
point
headed his times really
well anyway
moving on
uh Wally okay so here uh is Jimmy Lee
ready
I was just I was just messing there is
the funniest [ __ ] Jimmy Lee
developments you guys and I know y'all
probably don't want a long call so I'm
not going to but I promise this [ __ ] is
very funny
okay you want me to bring him in wait is
he really I gotta pee first there's
somebody's iPhone in the lobby it's
Jimmy gotta assume okay I'm gonna go pee
and we're just going to come back and do
a quick Jimmy Lee hit it's super funny
you guys trust me you're not going to
miss some of this [ __ ] these
developments I'll be right back okay
all right it's bathroom break time folks
you know you know the Vibes you know the
vibe all different flavors all different
flavors flavors
when the boss is away the children will
play neighbors I hope you all had a good
break out there in chat land and if
you're watching later when this is a
vlog you know what also I wanted to
include that I've been doing over break
is Legos
oh I've been seeing that heavy surprised
me dude Evian the [ __ ] Legos like I'm
heavily [ __ ] with I'm a dragon man
I'm not I'm using man the Lego trans I
[ __ ] love it where did that come from
were you a Lego guy growing up no
because I always used to get so
frustrated
um building them and like I'm just like
you know what [ __ ] it I'm gonna build it
I'm gonna do it right so I started with
the Mandalorian helmet and I built it
right and then I I ended up getting
every helmet in the [ __ ] collection
and then I built R2D2 and then I built
Ed Star Wars and then I built a [ __ ]
Porsche and then I built this Star Wars
what what did you say I built like a
Star Wars just a majority Star Wars
figures LEGOs okay I thought you said Ed
Star Wars for some reason I know it I
don't know I don't remember that
character my uh accountant had Star Wars
that's Ed Star Wars over there he's the
main character but yeah Legos has been
my [ __ ] and I [ __ ] love it well
that's cool yeah I love Legos when I was
a kid I'm running out of room though
that's the problem yeah
I used to have all of Hogwarts and Legos
I'm embarrassed to say nah that's badass
at all the Hogwarts yeah I want the Lord
of the Rings I've been you know I've
been chatting with Ian about it because
he's he's somewhat on the Lego train
um he sent me this Lord of the Rings the
the tower
and it's out of print and it's like
[ __ ] 800 the tower which Tower
because you know there's two
Legos and you son of a [ __ ] you
it's a good one you used to kind of a
[ __ ] you dance still got it we're still
sharp as ever oh got it
[Laughter]
you know Zach I mean sorry Dan texted me
over break and suggested I watch Andor
and I was like oh [ __ ] if Dan is is
pouching for something it must be really
good listen I've been super [ __ ] out
on Star Wars yeah for I don't know how
long ago did the last Star Wars movie
come out
horrible one 19 I think wait but you
watched Mandalorian though yeah I did I
was never really that hot on it to be
honest like it was it was fine it was
fine it wasn't trash but I never really
was that sucked into it but um
this new one I say see I asked
everybody's pretty good you know my
hesitation which you kind of turned that
off was uh I hated Rogue one
all right I hate it you guys
uh we're talking about Star Wars yeah
over here no I let it go I let it go for
a little bit Emperor's back
I'm fine
you said the emperor is back referring
to you because you're like a Sith Lord
right if I'm the emperor then you're
like uh I'm Vader I got your back Vader
okay I like that I don't care you can be
my Vader just don't ever shock my son
I can't make any promises about and he
doesn't I'm gonna [ __ ]
okay let's get off the analogy I'm
getting stuck all right let's let Jimmy
in we got some really exciting stuff to
talk about
okay I'm bringing them in old-timey all
right push
all different flavors
I wonder if he'll have his Pink's hat
today
did you hear pinks what was he kept
saying I got my Pink's hat on
I'm wearing my Pink's hat today Ethan
Jimmy there Ping's hot dog there he is
oh we got Dr Lee today oh wait yeah oh
okay
uh Dr Lee can we speak to Dr Lee
is this how you do your dentistry Dr Lee
[Music]
I would totally believe it if you walked
in looking like that did you work on my
teeth I'd be like totally fine
how about this oh
um that would be a problem are you a
bandana guy now that would be an issue
where are my pinks at all right Jimmy
listen we don't have a lot of time so I
just want to cut to the chase flavors
first of all congratulations didn't Joe
Rogan watch your clip
uh yeah he did it I have to tell you
think guess where I'm at where
the world famous Elena Wu restaurant in
Voorhees where the rich meet the famous
wait you're actually in a restaurant
right now yes
here we go if you eat here all your
dreams Ethan turned to [ __ ] oh well
don't eat really
fire the food down okay let me see you
already can I look around just move the
phone around I want to see the the
environment you're in the all the
different flavors I'm in a private room
because there's diners okay good idea
let's not send you the kids
let's just assume for the time being
that all the kitchen staff are legally
uh here
don't start that again don't push
all right well here I wanted to watch
the clip of you on Joe Rogan this is
super exciting and congratulations uh
here's Jimmy and Hillary thank you for
the nice email recording that Hill has
sent me a beautiful email and hell I
appreciate your support cool I did that
was really nice of you
um
[Applause]
thank you
I guess he's making a joke
do you see on where my Elena will hat
I did yeah
let's watch The Joe Rogan thing this is
great congrats man you must be buzzing
this [ __ ] goes out into the streets
and just says hilarious [ __ ] he's
implementing free speech in a way that's
just brilliant I saw him make fun of
this [ __ ] with one eye it was crazy
this guy is a [ __ ] Jersey Outlaw I
love him I got my eye on Wuhan got my
eye on you
got my eye on her
oh my god did you can you believe Joe
Rogan talked about you I mean you must
be buzzing
um I haven't slept for days even over
this well and also what what corresponds
with that is I I don't know if you've
noticed but you gained a ton of
Instagram followers recently I think I
think what I was telling Zach not that
he cared that I think the Instagram
followers went up uh because of Joe
Rogan and Zach said no no it's because I
know him and he did his music show and
he we had a little fight every night
because Zach said no no your files went
up because you're friendly with me and
I'm I'm a big famous music guy and I
said no it's Joe Rogan and we we figured
it out we we broke bread and eight nails
and everything's good this is crazy
because just um
what what I can't tell the date but
there's like a crazy jump like you
gained 130 000 new followers so it's all
it was all within the last 30 days all
within the last 30 years it was within
like you were growing very slow till
that but also we had the news Max and
the fox thing but it wasn't grown as
quick as it got hit well actually so
this the growth actually started before
Joe Rogan The Joe Rogan talked about you
so it's just been amazing you're paying
more attention than me I just realized
it started moving quick and uh Mason and
Carly thought it was because of of Joe
Rogan yeah really uh hat
I don't know
what do you think of the house I don't
know I don't know what the reference is
I feel like it must be I think it is
right yeah I did not might think that do
they have all different flavors there I
think Elena Wu is just the name of the
restaurant that he's at and so he's just
saying the famous Elena World restaurant
[Applause]
on the eighth which was a like to uh
last Sunday you gained you gained almost
15 000 new followers in a single day
have you seen the full episode of Joe
talking about you no I I got said that
by somebody on a DM on my Instagram and
then
this is cool I didn't even say it I just
got that here let me watch it again
because he's speaking so highly of you
he loves me it was just banana when are
you gonna go on his shows the question
is here let's watch [ __ ] goes out into
the streets and just says hilarious [ __ ]
he's implementing free speech in a way
that's just brilliant I saw him make fun
of this [ __ ] with one eye it was crazy
let's go he really that that's a little
out of line though juggling a little
harsh on her that I saw him make fun of
this [ __ ] with one eye that's out of
pocket he like he liked that Viral clip
of the one I like yeah I mean I like I
did laughs
and now I'm working in and out burger
now look
you really are the king of your crafting
I'm glad that you keep trying different
angles on the hat bag like it didn't
really you weren't really able to sell
it at the first time but you keep you're
persistent man yeah last time I was on
Ethan show I was wearing my face at you
remember I do I do well anyway I just
wanted to congratulate you on your huge
break with Joe Rogan which definitely is
a real clip and definitely happened
oh Ethan I love you and thanks for your
support and love and uh you guys are
stupid people I love used to death you
know well you'll always be a part of the
family and I just want to congratulate
you on your 100 completely organic
Instagram
surge I mean 130
000 new followers in one month that's
like that is that's super organic and
some people pay really a lot of money
for that you know so that amount of
followers yeah yeah did you pay for that
oh yeah yeah I mean I would never get
that many followers in such a short
amount of time without paying for it did
you pay for mine
no not with Dan paid for your father I
didn't Neighbors
wait do you know something about these
followers Jimmy
no but Dan sounds like he paid for him
the way he was saying that no I was just
saying it's nice and bought him for me
normally you have to pay big money to
get that many followers well unless
you're a superstar
as they're going through these followers
I'm seeing uh it's Joe Rogan must be
huge in India because there's a lot of
uh Indian followers here he is I have a
lot of it in advance yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I see that you know one of my Indian
fans is Dan huh who you connect with
with them you know you know no you're
one of my Indian fans their name sure oh
God here we go yeah no no no no no okay
no actually don't I I don't want to know
I don't know where this is going Jimmy
anything if he wants I'll tell Ethan I
think we gotta hear it we gotta here she
broke a lot of [ __ ] he's one of my fans
okay first of all that's I think that's
a Native American joke yeah so first of
all shame on you super races
and then we're talking about India the
country not Native Americans what was
his name again the layers
the layers of being wrong poke a lot of
[ __ ] he's been married four times Ethan
yes cheap poke a lot of trotties an old
friend of the families flavors very good
friends with love yeah we're we're
talking about the country of in India
yeah
oh you're not talking about Native
American Indians no no
now you tell me now but I see your
social media is buzzing so I'm surprised
you have 154 000 followers you're
dropping memes like this I must God damn
it I'm still not signed in you posted my
new memes dude this one's insane I mean
you have a picture of you with Andrew
Callahan you're the police and you're
about to apprehend him it says I don't
beg for [ __ ] I only asked 17 times and
that's it
correct now did you mate no no I'm just
gonna say it it's a little so today's
MLK day I thought it was a little
insensitive to post a picture of someone
graffiting on his mural that was super
out of pocket because we should be
celebrating him today you saw that
yeah why are you defacing MLK why are
you celebrating the facing MLK's statue
it was Zach that did that I didn't do
that okay all right
there was one that was like a holocaust
denial post and I thought that was like
okay
okay all right
well congratulations on all your success
Jimmy I just want to thank you guess
what I got some good news what's that
I'm coming out to LA in March all right
okay and I want the cameras in the
restaurant and I want all you guys to
come to the restaurant I want to create
fomo at one of the restaurants called
cincones and I need Dan to come too even
though he don't like me
maybe get your hair piece I don't know
whatever you want me to get you Dan I'll
do nothing yeah I'd love to talk to your
guy
okay Dan I'm getting one I can get you a
deal yeah a little two for one yeah
two different believers okay I think the
last time we tried to do man on the
street with Jimmy we were under this
misguided perception that we could
actually control this Unstoppable yeah I
think the ticket it should just go with
him and just film the chaos and Madness
just let him be himself he's going to do
it anyway right so don't get mad at us
we're just there to observe you know
it's like it's like when you're watching
a nature documentary and like a tiger's
eating like a defenseless baby deer and
you're like well why don't you help the
deer this is the this is the cycle of
life this is nature playing out and so I
think in much of the way we can document
Jimmy like a nature documentary can we
Ethan get everybody to a restaurant
where they would let us film and we
could rip it up would you do that or are
you nervous to do that what do you mean
rip it up though I create fomo as Zach
would say
uh Ethan I'm starting up Jimmy just uh
posted a meme uh him and Anne Frank
saying we're creating fomo what no that
was done by cam
wait okay wait that's disgusting bro
that's yeah that's always out there man
all right all right Jimmy listen we
gotta go congratulations it's all
happening for you buddy we love you
we'll see you in March all right let's
keep those followers coming up flavors
all right all right thank you Jimmy take
care everybody happy for you
love you bye bye there it is Jimmy Lee
was on uh Joe Rogan well okay so the
back story here is Zach told me that
there was a this deep pic of Joe Rogan
and then Jimmy thought it was genuinely
thought it was real and I was like
there's no [ __ ] way so I had to I had
to see for myself guys a [ __ ] Jersey
Outlaw this is like there's apps where
you can this is a fake yeah there's apps
it's really easy to do right yeah it's
just it's like it does it over your face
and covers your face and mouth movement
because you can see it's got my eye on
Wuhan got my eye on you I thought it was
just taking out a context
yeah no it's just a deep fake okay
I guess
go ahead oh I'm sorry sorry uh I was
talking to him on the phone uh
last week and he was telling me about
this and
um he's like can you believe it I just I
didn't want to burst this bubble man oh
my god oh you couldn't break it though I
couldn't bring and he's like I'm getting
all these new followers yeah so I don't
know I mean obviously he's buying like a
lot of followers it's not just followers
too whenever he posts within like one
minute he'll have 2 000 likes too and
then but that's awesome I love that he's
just you know I love the dedication man
it's all the different flavors happening
I love the theory if he's like somebody
can watch this if I can convince them
that other people like it then maybe
they'll fall in line and like it he's
creating fomo literally they're doing it
right yeah well the chat is as always
entirely uh divided on the Jimmy content
as I knew they were English but I made
an exception today uh for Jimmy
and I'm just so happy for his continued
success there
what do you think he means tear up a
restaurant together he's just it's an
old-timey expression dude he's he tear
it up you get a bunch of laughter what
does he want to do in the restaurant do
what he does he's gonna walk around to
the patrons and
take some food from a guy with an oxygen
you know what's interesting about these
bot accounts is that the pictures don't
line up like there's like multiple
pictures of different people on these
accounts like it's the worst fake
accounts I've ever seen
yeah I think honestly what's happening
is he's getting
um
he's been taken for a ride by these PR
people because we he always talks about
how much he's paying and he's got this
huge scheme and they're just like
they're like look because he's so
clueless
[ __ ] up oh yeah they're straight up
stealing from him if that's what's
really happening it has to be I don't
think Jimmy no he Jimmy doesn't know
[ __ ] you probably don't even know you
can buy followers on Instagram yeah and
so I think they're like yo look how big
you're getting on Instagram and he's
like okay I guess the twenty thousand
dollars a month on paying them is worth
it
yeah flavors they made the Deep fake
they're they are he's being you should
actually tip them off yeah we should
definitely warn him if that's really
what I I think I just thought he's just
buying followers because think about it
Jimmy doesn't know how to do that
but he would no he personally wouldn't
but I thought maybe he he told you know
his people to do it yeah exactly or
something like that but what you're
saying actually I don't know how much it
would cost to buy followers it's
expensive so wouldn't he would have to
know because that would be like a huge
no he's paying them a shitload of money
if he's paying this PR firm a bunch of
money and they're like look we're doing
our job so well look how many followers
you're getting and it's all fake yeah
like if he's paying him ten thousand
dollars a month and then they spend like
a thousand a month or whatever yeah a
month interesting like his followers are
big
um some websites were like ten thousand
for sixty five dollars so oh so ten
thousand for sixty five dollars yeah
send me that link boy
I'm about to be okay I'm about to be
more followed than Kim K
Ardon the biggest Fallen account on
Instagram with a hundred trillion
followers
um it's straight up elder abuse
in a way I think he's being elderly
abused
somebody said he's a job Creator shut up
that's true he's me I think there's a
crime happening to be honest yeah you
should tip him off Zach okay let him
just let him down lightly that he might
be on the receiving end of other reviews
what else we got here
we I guess we should probably talk about
some of the main stories eh
um
oh [ __ ] this one's so funny I gotta
watch it
this happened during our break Joe Rogan
to speak on him again I grew up this man
is so embarrassing [ __ ] dumb how dude
you've got to be so ashamed like Joe
Rogan's biggest problem is that he
doesn't research [ __ ] and he says all
kinds of dumb crap and he's been getting
tons of [ __ ] for it and then after all
the [ __ ] he's been getting he goes out
and makes this sad sad sob story he's
watched a clip of dad beating the [ __ ]
out of Matt Watson from the first
Creator clash and in his mind he's built
this whole narrative about how it's a
dad beating up his son and it's tragic
and it's sad and what a world we live in
did this happen over the Breakthrough oh
my God so much time has passed it's been
a long break man oh my God but I mean
this is like yeah this was really
shocking without my dad so for me I was
like no his dad was probably an [ __ ]
his dad's probably jealous his dad's
probably just some terrible this is
terrible people that [ __ ] people and
have kids
murderers monsters thieves con artists
they [ __ ] people and have kids and then
they have a son I saw a video today of a
boxing match between a father and a son
no it made me so sad dude just pause and
reflect oh my God this is the man who's
educating and forming and influencing
millions of young men and he's sitting
there crying about a stupid [ __ ]
internet meme like guys he's like how is
he gonna go immediately with that
narrative and not even be for a second
like well let me double check that
I know he doesn't he's like so bad and
it's so important that he fact check his
[ __ ] he's probably high on DMT or some
[ __ ] when he saw
made me so sad
because there's this young kid he looks
like he's probably like 17 or 18 and the
father's 42. and the father beats the
[ __ ] out of him oh my God I mean like
dings him in the head and keeps punching
him because that's your son
that's your son dude and we're watching
you beat your son up because I get your
son probably got cocky with you but and
he celebrates after he knocks his son
out it made me so sad because first of
all I'm like that kid has brain damage
now 100 maybe it's just a little where
did he even come up with it where did he
I can't believe he's serious where did
he come with the brain damage I don't
know he got bopped in the head a few
times I think he did have to go to the
hospital later on for like a potential
minor concussion but yeah I mean it was
I just I love how he's like this dude
for sure got brain damage he's [ __ ]
for life now like he like he looked into
it or something
meanwhile he just got Dad's name super
confused yeah he just saw Dad and he was
like oh son by the way like even looking
at them they there's no way visibly
looking at them that they're related no
way and they're almost like it's like
Dad is like maybe 10 years older at most
well anyway here this is actually I
don't want to watch this whole thing
because
was this idubbz that made this edit I
believe it was it was Matt who made it
or I thought it was I think he said wait
where is it what the [ __ ] is this
account
where oh it's in the dock okay yeah I
think Matt said items made it but
whoever made it
Matt Watson posted this and oh yeah
sorry it was items it was items today
and it's so [ __ ] funny holy [ __ ] you
guys this was like video of the Year for
me of a boxing match between a father
and a son
it made me so sad so sad it made me so
sad wait is this music operated do we
know I upload it's fine it's good okay
because there's this young kid he looks
like he's probably like 17 or 18 and the
father's 42. and the father Beats 42.
I mean like dings him in the head and
keeps punching him I'm like that's your
son
that's your son
and we're watching you beat your son up
because I get your son probably got
cocky with you but and he celebrates
after he knocks his son out it made me
so sad because first of all I'm like
that kid has brain damage now 100 maybe
it's just a little maybe he'll be fine
maybe he'll get over it but maybe you
[ __ ] him up that can happen too he
might be depressed from now on after
that he might [ __ ] up this pituitary
gland it happens to people and you just
did that to your son you're supposed to
like touch him up you're supposed to not
even hurt him like slam him in the body
a little bit like you think he can fight
okay good dude kill this little have a
little boxing match you don't tee off on
your son's face on television it's crazy
it sure is how was how old was the kid
kid looks young to me he looks like you
know he could be 20. he could be 19.
and the father's kind of jacked not too
jacked but you know he's fit and he
could [ __ ] punch he knows how to box
and the sun doesn't look like he has any
idea what the [ __ ] he's doing I don't
know what the thing was like someone
sent it to me and they were like
cheering that this old guy knocked his
son out I was like yeah I wonder why
maybe I should look foreign
[Music]
I'm such a sucker
not only are you stuck
with stuff like you created that whole
[ __ ] world in your head if that story
is true though he is so right
like Matt has Daddy written on his chest
and just like pen like ink pen like that
should have like been a clue I think
that this isn't wrong all of it the
whole event like just look at it for a
second I think this really epitomizes
George I mean it says so much about him
yeah it's so profoundly embarrassing
you know I I'm editing a video I haven't
worked out a while about uh the Creator
Clash I was watching the footage and I
didn't see this I have not watched it
back but me and Matt are in the locker
room before he goes out to fight I'm
like hey man you got this go go teach
that old man a lesson he ain't [ __ ] he
walks out like we're never gonna see him
again but I had no idea how it was going
I was just [ __ ] around but funny now
knowing the context of everything uh
thank you Bella Simmons the great Bella
Simmons for 50 gifted love you
David Whispers
thank you
Zach for the love of God please use he
might be depressed from now on after
that I was gonna go through him that's a
good idea the one where he says Brogan
says I'm a sucker like that's pretty
good I'll go through and pull pull some
of those also can I get a shout out my
boyfriend just cheated on me who's that
from yeah shout out [ __ ] him Alice in
the Wonderland [ __ ] that idiot [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ]
dick
do you think watching that clickback do
you think Dad went too hard on Matt like
I always feel bad he's like Matt
literally
doesn't know anything like it's just sad
watching that almost
I don't know about going too hard I
don't know it's hard to tell I think
that like the adrenaline probably like
he just wanted to yeah get it all out
yeah
my coach told me not to do that too he
said a lot of people their first fight
they get scared and that's kind of what
I did like I told Dan my strategy then
when I went in there I completely just
switched it up
so I don't know I guess when you go in
the uh the ring you got to be ready
that's what your coach was kind of
saying yeah
are you gonna do a full episode on Tate
Michael asked um
I don't know if there's that much to say
about it
okay has there been any updates since
like are we still gonna talk about him
today there is good updates yeah there
is really good updates
should we do God there's so much great
stuff I mean God let me just look at the
MLK statue
uh real fast 10 million dollar statue
honoring MLK Jr the great Martin Luther
King Jr in Boston just dropped
here it is what
what it looks like someone's holding a
big fat [ __ ] turd or intestines or a
giant like it is hideous oh my God bag
of turret you know flaming turd bag so
okay so this is supposed to be two
arms hugging each other
dude look at that that is just that's
it's like creepy weird that looks like
intenses yeah like
or someone going down on a on somebody
maybe prolapse
it's based on a photo of him hugging his
wife but it does not look anything like
yep they forgot the important part is
him and his wife ow
e it's massive like the the hands are
good you know they got the fingers and
the detail for sure
the sleeve bro there's nothing I'm okay
about this but what is this part is the
little third yeah they're holding it's
been 10 million bucks on this and I
think people pointed out that and it's
true Martin Luther King I'm sure would
have
thought of a better way to spend 10
million dollars helping people
than a giant statue but that was pretty
funny and I don't know if you guys know
about this phenomenon
but apparently on MLK Day
there's like crazy Club Flyers where
they have big MLK parties MLK weekend
I'm okay yeah so and so what do you mean
so there's clubs
that are throwing MLK parties okay and
they do these craziest flyers and
apparently this is the thing that
everyone gets hyped for
and he says hold up y'all getting out of
hand with these MLK party Flyers here is
here he is uh with a stack of cash up
against his head
and Harriet Tubman yeah that's a gang
Buster right there here he is what MLK
doesn't deserve this we gotta start
locking these party promoters
this is [ __ ] crazy dude I'm okay with
the Golden Crown 40 ouncer and something
else
that's wild isn't that I mean [ __ ] it's
funny as [ __ ] but God damn the MLK sorry
so my favorite ones at the end doesn't
say don't close it yet the MLK weekend
flyers for the parties will always be
fun in this house so apparently this is
a thing Baton Rouge had to represent
here he is with a chain
and he's ready to party this one for the
I don't know gigolatas I can't think
gigoladas
I don't even know I've never heard it
this one for the gigoladas
dude so that's amazing that's gonna be a
good party right there
and uh
there's more
I had a dream big booty jam
Up in Smoke so
it's crazy out there you guys
uh this is yeah that was it I don't know
man it's just Fortnight level of
disrespect I mean
I mean yeah these
a lot of times it's at strip clubs that
I've seen Flyers like this where it's
just like whatever it is whatever's
going on that weekend it's like Labor
Day or this or that and they'll somehow
make that the theme of the party which
is never actually the theme but like
yeah the MLK ones are obviously wild Liv
said I work in a hospital and there are
a solid amount of old guys who love
getting a straight catheter
way more than you'd think oh well until
you try it dude there is ain't no way
that feels good
why old guys
like is it just old guys maybe here your
hole gets looser from yeah I wonder
[Music]
I need Lyft to give us more info I mean
it's mostly old guys getting getting
them right oh true I guess catheters
yeah old man a jig a lot of we have a
definition guys an ecstasy pill oh what
or a person that is under the influence
of ecstasy a person that can dance a
gigolo jiggle a tin manner bouncing in a
fast motion
all right
there it is
Sam said she used to collect Club fires
in college she had one that said Call of
Duty and it was Cod themed oh yeah I
remember she told me that once they used
to put them on our cars every like
so annoying
David is asking you to please say stop
every time I bring up uh shoving things
in the dick
I leave that to you about that just a
suggestion
all right let's get to the main story so
you're asking if there was some Andrew
Tate updates there has been a lot
actually
um
I'm not trying to be depressing so I
want to get like to the details mostly I
just want to get into like how [ __ ] he
is he is Mega [ __ ] no so
um the update is basically he was he was
arrested and detained for 30 days they
keep trying to appeal it and the judge
is like no you're staying they now have
the option to extend it to like
150 days or something of Kipping him
yeah wow
that's serious him and his brother and
his collaborators wow
and um
the claims is that the women claim
they're being forced by the British
Brothers uh
the current arrest they've seized all of
his cars they're gonna sell all of his
super cars to pay for the investigation
and to go to the victims how badass wow
what color is his Bugatti now
clear okay
[Music]
dude that's the best they've impounded
all of his cars and they're selling four
million dollars worth of assets
started from the Tweet about the cars to
to Greta very true that's amazing it's
so good it's like the greatest story
it's always under investigation for a
long time before that but the timing was
the diet this this whole story is like
amazing yesterday we found out there's
been like an ongoing high level okay
deep investigation for nine months
including like a Romanian FBI
anti-terror unit serious [ __ ] I think
what happened with him is that he was
paying off like people and local police
but he
he flew too close to the Sun as they say
and attracted
fish that were way too big for him to
handle
and so the FBI is basically of Romania
set up this really elaborate
investigation including wiretapping they
have wire Taps of him saying crazy [ __ ]
yeah
mega mega [ __ ] and people keep saying is
he gonna go I think he's gonna go to
jail for like 15 years like he is done
cooked cooked
um I have small dick energy
um let's see they They seized his cars
his watches
just straight cash she had they just
took all of his [ __ ]
damn it is the Matrix bro The Matrix got
you got him
his own Justice in 2023. I think he's
going down hard they say the authorities
in Romania said the police served search
warrants at five homes I took four
suspects into custody including the two
brothers
uh and and dude this okay so this stuff
gets a little crazy this was all on
on uh
I guess the Girl recorded it
this is crazy this girl recorded this
conversation of him
and she went to the UK police and said
hey this guy's forwarded me you need to
do something here's the evidence of him
and they didn't do [ __ ] Hassan actually
when I was on his stream told me
something really interesting that the UK
has like a a really systematic
problem with Prosecuting sexual crimes
like they were like not believing women
not following up and statistically the
amount of cases that they were trying
versus the amount reported was like
insanely insanely insanely low wow so
it's a recent development now where the
UK is trying to get that number up and
get more because it was like a big
Scandal so this happened during that big
scandal
where they were not like going after
sexual predators and the listen I mean
this is a trigger warning uh but here's
the audio that she recorded
and sent to the police Vice news got
this from the girl
and um
and published it so again trigger
warning it's a minute long
it's an audio message
it's just audio yeah oh it's an audio
messages he sent her so here it is here
it is audio notes
am I a bad person because the more you
didn't like it the more I enjoyed it I
[ __ ] yeah
yes
whoa I'll answer it yeah question for
you yes all right I'm not going to pause
it am I a bad person because the more
you didn't like it the more I enjoyed it
I [ __ ] loved how much you hated it
turned me on oh my God why am I like
that
why I am one of the most dangerous men
on this planet sometimes you forget
exactly how lucky you were to get [ __ ]
by me would you rather me pin you down
and make you do things you didn't like
or would you rather [ __ ]
you didn't like the I was thinking I can
do whatever I want to
that's what it is I'm the smartest
person on this [ __ ] planet Are you
seriously so offended I strangled you a
little bit you didn't [ __ ] pass out
chill the [ __ ] out Jesus Christ I
thought you were cool what's wrong with
you wow this is a voice note that was in
possession of the UK police they were
doing an investigation we found out one
of the things we found out is he was
kicked off Big Brother mysteriously I
don't know if you heard this but the
news so Vice has been doing really good
reporting on this they found out the
reason he was removed from Big Brother
is because he was under investigation by
the police for our word and when they
found that out they said you got to get
off the show Jesus so this guy has a
long-standing history of uh
of doing this kind of stuff and so there
there's one that that was one thing that
broke
um
dude that's so [ __ ] up I get turned on
when you hear me yeah
uh Vice report said that the WhatsApp
messages and voice notes
uh from this girl says he R worded her
in 2013.
she said the police told her they
believe her account but authorities
declined to prosecute
foreign
this is what is this one
oh is this the what's up messages
oh so a recreate so this is the message
you sent as Vice reported and uh again
trigger warning guys just give me like a
minute here but these again just to show
you he says I love odd wording you and
watching you let me while still debating
if it's a good idea or not monsters are
monsters when you're under my control I
do whatever I please you were my poor
when I had my hands on you
wow
okay
um you know if I I know that Tate's fans
are gonna be like she's lying and she
liked it like that video of him like oh
yeah she like there's it was consensual
it's like if she has these messages and
she says she was R worded she was like
there's no [ __ ] room for today I
always ask for proof and usually these
are the kind of things you can't prove
if you unless you're in the room but
this is as close as you can he's having
evidence the smartest man in the world
loves just loves putting his own crimes
in writing yeah like that is his
favorite thing to do is let me record
myself detailing all of my well wait if
you think that's smart wait to see the
next [ __ ] this next stuff isn't trigger
warning but yeah okay but I just want to
say his fans think those voice notes
aren't real by the way they're arguing
that that's not him in those voice
members oh okay I think the reason why
because when I listen to it I had that
thought too yeah it's because they're
tight little voice notes and they edit
them together so it sounds a little
artificial but it's definitely him guys
come on don't be [ __ ] morons
so he so he was caught on wire tape
wiretap admitting to money laundering
and other crimes was transcribed by a
Romanian news website
called digi24 it reads Tate you're not
stupid and you can probably guess how
much
I make so much how I make so much money
I have to hide what I'm really doing the
victim said webcam Tate responded for a
long time I did this with the team of
girls working on video chat the company
was fake but this is how I laundered my
dirty money some of the girls who worked
for me I used them to do other things to
move money or illegal things documents
Etc I will never do that with you you're
different baby yeah
and then I had never seen these videos
and I don't know where
wait I don't want I don't want this
lawyer talking about I want the video I
I couldn't find the original videos so
so it's just him watching it yeah and he
gives a little bit of commentary his
commentary is good though so I mean it's
not it's not so this video that came out
I don't know where it came from but it's
so [ __ ] crazy
this must have been like part of water
University from what I understood it was
the predecessor to Hustler University
but it was a similar scam that he was
running where he was educating people
about basically how to run a him
organization dude listen to this this is
the advice he's giving to men and and
y'all really wondering if he's just
listen it's mind-blowing tax is also
another important element of controlling
your woman
you're not going to pay anybody tax
because you're getting paid in Bitcoin
so you don't need to pay tax to anybody
that's not right that's not real that's
not real oh my God our God that's for
sure not right is that what guys are
saying that he's like helped them so
much and so inspired Rush when that
Stacks first he's like yo I don't think
yo Andrew says I don't pay taxes if I
get paid in Bitcoin because like you
hear so much about guys saying I look up
to him he helped me so much
50 50. that's not even the craziest part
so that you're paying the tax
because girls are lazy you're not stupid
and girls don't understand how taxes
work so the girl he says as he's 16. it
sounds like you're not understanding oh
my God
the nuances
of not paying taxes yeah oh hello
Bitcoin
although there wasn't there was a time
like when Bitcoin wasn't audited but it
wasn't that long I think I don't know
the thing is Bitcoin it's hard to track
and so it's it's much easier when you
take it out into your bank then they
[ __ ] know exactly and that's it's not
that it's legal or that you don't get
taxed on bitcoin it's that you can
theoretically hide it a lot easier than
you could but you can't use it without
being taxed exactly
not supposed to do that yes exactly you
can easier yes you know well there's
laws about it now so I guess now he's
just having a big joke out of it I mean
I I mean at least in America I'm not
sure what the legal system is in Romania
or UK or wherever the [ __ ] he was when
he was doing this but again again
this it gets way crazier yeah we've made
this much money but I'm gonna pay the
tax to make sure we don't get in trouble
she'll sit there go okay okay
now that allows you to do two things one
is another control element see how that
control is is a recurring theme over and
over and over again I work with him my
tax is not a problem if I do it alone I
have to deal with taxes taxes are
complicated so control element and he
doesn't have respect for these women at
all because he thinks they're stupid it
allows you to pay her a smaller
percentage
so I used to pay my girls 13.
so for every ten thousand dollars they
made I give them three and I keep seven
they thought they were on fifty percent
and I said that the disparity is because
of taxes so you're on fifty percent and
we had to pay the tax first and then
it's 50 50. this man is literally
recording himself he's doing fraud yeah
to like tax fraud and normal fraud like
two layers of fraud Happening Here
scamming people and that's your
Technique guys for self-improvement just
watch this okay like guys this man
filmed himself doing this and he's just
smart what the [ __ ] smartest man alive
is helping young men Ethan he's so
inspiring
stuff bro
is this mind-bending [ __ ] and what I
can't get over is like how this video is
so underground apparently yeah I don't
know how it Unearthed all of a sudden
but man wow I'm sure the police got it
oh yeah let's think of how to dig
ourselves out of this
it's on video
on camera you say because I'm the one
typing I'm
already you're working in I'm the one
paying the bills the electricity I'm the
one who's uh and electricity and
everything
what was that you know what there was
something
he just mentioned something and this was
a detail that because I watched most of
this video and he talks about how he
doesn't do this anymore but when he was
starting his business he was having
these cam girls perform or whatever and
then they would chat with guys as well
they kept saying I don't actually have
the girls do that I was doing that it
did yes and so this dude who's doing
phone sex with him no yeah well not
phone check but that's like five percent
like chatting he was cyber sexing with
dudes at like until he got successful
enough that he says then then he hired
people and they took over doing that but
he very casually was just like talking
about how he was this guy hey baby what
are you wearing yeah I just thought that
was that's why his conversations would
add in adding Ross are going so well so
authentic right he's got a lot of
experience yeah it is just another
paying client exactly
this shit's crazy dude so this is nuts
right I mean this is really something
this is mind-blowing I already knew you
know the guy was a piece of [ __ ] like
scum to the scummiest level but this is
just when you're talking about like
crying so in your face he's just saying
it all awesome dude that's awesome it's
so good you're working in I'm the one
paying the bills the electricity I'm the
one who's uh and the electricity and
every other maintenance cost of this
property I'm the one who bought the
equipment I'm the one who knows what
he's doing I'm the one with the
knowledge
shut the [ __ ] up go online
and they should be pretty happy with
that they respect you as a person
overall so really you're paying 30 you
tell them you're paying 50. the
difference is in the tax
that's where the disparity lies taxes if
you if they don't believe you or they
want to get fresh or whatever print out
some tax forms I see this all the time
it's pronounce them randomly what's
crazy it's like just lie lie lie lie lie
whatever it is that you need just lie
about it thank you he's just real
psychopath this is like really
Psychopathic Behavior yeah what's crazy
is he's going to give them 15 only
because he or is it 30 30
but then on that 30 they're still gonna
owe taxes of course
no transparency the number is whatever
it wants it to be yeah because there's
nothing expenses
now he goes oh yeah and I faked
documents too yeah fake tax forms you
fake it there's another big crime right
there smartest man in the world right
here wow knowledge
shut the [ __ ] up go online
and they should be pretty happy with
that if they respect you as a person
overall so really you're paying 30 you
tell them you're paying 50. the
difference is in the tax
that's where the disparity lies taxes
come on if you if they don't believe you
they want to get fresh or whatever print
out some tax forms let's do this all the
time dude you're filming this and
putting it online
fake
fraudulently fake tax forms are you used
to do it all the time all the time
regularly
holy [ __ ] what a idiot and the thing is
is that this on its own probably
almost definitely wouldn't have been
enough to get them because
um you could just say he was
bullshitting or whatever right you know
what I mean like him saying this alone
isn't enough to charge him but
they with all of the documentation that
they have got on him and everything
um and wiretapping and hearing him talk
about this in private then something
like this becomes corroborating evidence
for all of the things and all of a
sudden it's like well no you're not
lying you're detailing your criminal
Empire right well also these are easy to
follow up especially if they have his
his victims they can they can trace all
this [ __ ] back right check the taxes and
all this [ __ ] and I think he's going to
get nailed for this one for wire fraud
for money laundering right it's not even
just human trafficking at this point
wow somebody said [ __ ] thought
he was in a deposition
that's so funny like a Depo video
deposition Academy
holy [ __ ] dude it's like you didn't make
the plea deal yet bro
you don't have to be that honest doing
good
yeah somebody said if Trisha thought
five percent was bad
imagine if Andrew Tate was their partner
all right
tax forms so yeah sign here and sign
this what is it it's for the tax you
want to pay the tax or not
oh okay and they just sign away I don't
know the [ __ ] sign in let's throw
them away afterwards
something real is happening nothing's
happening looks like medium or HP
nothing's happening
this is crazy so dumb
nothing's happening but I'm getting rich
[ __ ] it's happening
let's see what the lawyer has to say
about it you're getting rich [ __ ]
that's what he just said he couldn't so
he's taking another 20 of what would
have been their earnings uh-huh saying
he's paying taxes but he's not paying
taxes his words having them even sign a
dummy tax form
that is just to try to convince her even
more that that he's paying some taxes
which is just ridiculous super and so
what is the middle word
fraud yes that's fraud Force fraud or
coercion anyway so tax is another
important element to keep control of the
girl you have to talk to girls you could
not do a business relationship with a
female I'll tell you why
women have sex
with somebody if they're not [ __ ] you
they're [ __ ] somebody else now a
woman is always going to be the most
loyal to the guy she's talking as
opposed to anyone else for any other
reason
her work for you you say look
I'm gonna have a brain damage here's
your car here's my Cutler work together
blah blah blah here's the [ __ ] I've
had dudes I've known loads of guys who's
like try to do a contract with a girl
anyway whatever he goes on it's all bad
but then now he goes on to detail how
exactly how he human trafficks people he
actually put this [ __ ] on camera so we
got the fraud uh but now here's here's
the really good stuff uh quote unquote
good stuff
let me explain it to you properly in
fact I'll bring one of the girls who
works for me
you your Bolton [ __ ] the new girl you
go out for [ __ ] a nice dinner your
Bolton [ __ ] is the one who does the
selling you don't do the selling the
girl has to hear from a girl and this is
where your bottom [ __ ] has to be
trained so I said it's so important to
have a good first girl remember Glenn
Maxwell that was the girl that recruited
for Jeffrey Epstein almost identical to
what he's talking about here that's what
I keep saying he's just he's he's
Jeffrey Epstein Junior yeah yeah
foreign
he thinks he invented pimping by the way
context you have the way he structured
his business
one of the ways that he's lured the
girls by having another girl there
identical to what
um Epstein was doing
now
and this is the this is a danger when
you have so much stuff that's out there
that's reckless right let's see what he
has to say about the the uh Romanian
court system
and their jails
they're corruption free as we all know
let's put me in jail I'm gonna walk in
there with a pile of money like this I'm
gonna walk in there that worked for you
like this can you walk in there with a
pile of money
actually funny he went in there and they
went and took this money and we've kept
his ass there
right didn't work out quite the way you
envisioned
he's now in a jail
in Romania this video is actually is now
by the way hats off to CLR Bruce Rivers
this is actually he has all the receipts
yeah this man came so far a lot of uh go
off bro I wasn't familiar with him
how did he do this I wasn't familiar
with him until I saw this video I just
stumbled upon this it was just on my
front page of YouTube oh he's a big
Channel actually 700 yeah I was about to
say a lot of people in our chat seem
familiar with him and say they're
they're good to his so I I like he he
loves these Rock videos it's so fun wait
he raps no he he reviews rap videos with
like guns in it oh say incriminating
yeah that's awesome
he's a criminal defense lawyer right
professionally like he's not a
prosecutor because I think he generally
comes from it from the angle of like
here's what not to do really like don't
don't self-report your crimes you know
what I mean
um he's perfectly qualified he thought
yeah he says up front in this video
though that he does not like Andrew Tate
but he makes a point which I think is
good that I'm gonna watch this entire
video because no matter what with all of
Andrew Tate's fans they always tell you
you're taking him out of context blah
blah so I'm not going to take anything
out of context I'm gonna watch this
entire video of him describing his
business and we'll go from there they
just don't watch it they just they're
like ah he's just another hater no no
yeah he's just a hater this old this
[ __ ] guys just a hater lawyer ass
[ __ ] right going to be subject to the
courts in Romania he just on this video
I'm sure the prosecutors have this
because I have it if I haven't they
haven't yeah cloudy
taunting
showing complete and utter disregard for
the remaining court system which he's
now going to be facing now if you recall
the statement from his own lawyer said
Mr Tate has nothing but the utmost
respect
for the court system well that's not
what it says here so what what I'm
trying to get at here is the case for
them to be made and
granted women may come here by their own
will or come to Romania and work for him
did the human trafficking part is it
before or is it next because
there's a lot more I thought oh it was
just specifically about the the Jews
Lane I mean there is it's scattered
throughout the whole video so I don't
know I just wanted to highlight the part
where he points out the Epstein
connections
as he calls it so effectively what
webcam company doing it is doing is is
mining Bitcoin but in fact it's sort of
mining Bitcoin the traditional way with
huge electricity expenses and massively
expensive equipment with space and
cooling all Apple [ __ ] you mind Bitcoin
we're supposed to get titties you mine
Bitcoins
but that's what he just said I take that
out of context
dude he's awesome go off Bruce Bruce is
King dude
entertain although I'm not a fan and I
don't care to even pretend that I'm I
think but it's an interesting case it's
an interesting case because it has
International intrigue
but you also have from his own words
the control aspect how important it is
to control these women I I think the
government with this video with just
this one video alone that's an excellent
Foundation wow for the sex trafficking
Church whoa but more than that they also
have
otter probably a tax beef that they
could Levy against him once they start
diving into his books oh he's analyzing
this I really don't want you to think
I'm taking anything out of context
because I'm not but let's see in his own
words how he's recruited Lord or
retain these girls
you see he's cooked he's like [ __ ]
done done done yeah when this first
the news first happened in my mind it
was just like ah people like him nothing
bad ever happens to them or whatever but
when you really break it down and you
factor in the whole fact that he so
publicly was like yeah I'm just gonna
pay off the police uh they're corrupt it
doesn't matter yeah
um he really [ __ ] cornered himself
with that because I mean even if they
were corrupt and that was an option
before now it's not because he
specifically said that and so they're
not gonna they're gonna intentionally
double down on going after him to prove
that you know they're on the up and ups
there's only one man that who could get
him out of this
do you have a Authority in Romania
credentials
you know what when he gets sentenced to
like 20 years or whatever we should all
send him fan mail that's like looks like
we're a door a doors and when he opens
it's like [ __ ] you pig rot let's go
awesome
just to keep the heat on him in prison
things like
oh yeah but you're always working I have
to do some traveling and you can't come
I want to bring you with me traveling is
a great one because the thing is about
this business is mobile if you can find
a good Airbnb with good internet you can
run it somewhere else so it's a good
little caveat to throw in uh and you're
always working why don't you work for me
so we spend more time together or if
you're doing well so we'll have a webcam
business oh I don't want to do that so
okay I know you don't want to do that
but listen come let's have a meeting
let's just talk about it we don't want
to do it don't do it this is the party
yeah yeah so he is so again
yeah wild [ __ ] yo and again this whole
video is actually worth a good watch
yeah because
yeah he's [ __ ] so I mean that's good
that's great right there yeah I think
that's that's awesome I mean I think
it's I'm just really happy about this to
be honest oh yeah and his they his peeps
they go oh so you're happy that there's
victims I was hoping he was innocent
which means there's no victims what I
swear to God that's what somebody says
no a lot that's like a popular argument
they go oh so let me get this straight
you're hoping that there's victims by
saying that you want him to go to jail
oh my God swear to God this people have
been saying that wow I swear you'll see
it out there you'll see it
by the way I've seen multiple people in
the chat say that they think that I'm
trying to be uh Andrew Tate right now
with I guess I guess it's the glasses
and the Blazer or whatever this was my
Morpheus outfit from earlier so I guess
I'll I don't want to look like Tate so
I'll take that you don't look like Tate
stop it
Daniels I keep seeing it that's the game
that's the game yeah so there you go
that's pretty good up like positive
update like shocking all of it yeah I
can't believe how much there is already
out there yeah
yeah there's no way it's coming back no
he's cooked I'm ready put me in jail
he's he's so [ __ ]
so yeah so that's awesome
um also
we had this back and forth with Aiden
Ross who's now banned on Twitch
um
I was trying to reach out to him mostly
about Andrew Tate
I'm trying to get through to this kid
that this is not a good guy no and
um
oh did we ever watch that we never
watched the Bradley Martin clip on the
main show yeah all of that happened
during break because I think a lot of
y'all will appreciate if you can get me
that time stamp
Bradley Martin went on the nelk podcast
and he challenged them a little bit
because I did Bradley's podcast and we
had a conversation about Andrew
and uh I actually got through to him
because he went on the nelk podcast and
they were talking about Andrew Tay and
he brought up
some of the [ __ ] I told him
about the human trafficking
and he was in he was he even like had
the receipts ready yes I saw and he
pulled it and showed them and then by
the way their reaction is so [ __ ]
insane sorry to Yahoo who saw this on
the members only live but this is really
good I have a I don't know if you guys I
did I did a pod with H3 yesterday right
but I have a question about this like do
you guys have you ever looked at his
website where he was talking about what
like prior to I don't know the other
stuff somebody just said I have like six
drinks in front of me I don't know I
have so many [ __ ] drinks I pointed
that out before the show and you were
like I need variety and well God damn
not like a beverage guy what do you mean
God damn you asked for it
I know I know he's having it right now
okay
oh
only Gamers up
are adored are adoring sponsors
spelling but he was on his website
talking about
um his process of getting women for the
cam girl thing yeah do you guys know if
that is true have you seen these what
was the process again like this is this
is just stuff that I see and I'm just
this is Devil's Advocate now at this
point because the whole thing that I'm
trying to see is like if he's actually
convicted for sex trafficking like it's
[ __ ] it's going to be a really bad
thing of course so I heard it was money
laundering though that's what I heard
too but then somebody who knows these
guys are such [ __ ] dumb idiots they talk
about fake news they're creating it I
never heard it was money wondering I
never heard it was whatever I gotta like
y'all are like making [ __ ] up y'all so
dumb it's so unwilling to do like the
smallest amount of research uh the the
irony of Aiden shaving his head at this
point I need to look like Tate is it
makes it so much more beautiful oh yeah
that was my original beef with him is
that he did like this whole homage to
Tate yeah free tape he shaved his head
and [ __ ]
so dumb just and then again I thought he
got released it's just so much fake news
so yeah
you are the fake news just do a tiny bit
of research go read one just listen to
freaking articles talking to you right
now and some or all of the people who
have been trying to tell you for a year
right it's not like new he's like God I
just know what to believe and then it's
like a course of people being like
Andrew here's all the receipts and you
take did all this [ __ ] he's like God I
just don't know what to believe
this is the thing I don't know if this
is true or not but apparently Tate had a
website in which he wrote out like what
he was doing like and it was I think it
was almost like a self-help version to
like teach guys how to almost in a sense
get girls and again I I can't bro I wish
I had that idea to show him at the time
I can't like believe that everybody's
calling it self-help like
irony
yeah that's that's a tough one I mean so
I don't know if self-help is supposed to
become at the expense of
help me [ __ ] you I don't know the weird
self-help died it's a Vibe right now
Psychopaths guide to self-help I mean I
guess me [ __ ] you I like that yeah maybe
that's a good title for a book say this
is 100 true because I didn't see the
website myself but I'm looking at these
screenshots and uh there's this thing
that says my job was to get women to
fall in love with me like this is a
screenshot from the website I don't know
if this was his website
um he said literally that was my job my
job was to meet a girl go on a few days
sleep with her tested she's quality get
her to fall in love with me to where
she'd do anything I'd say and then get
her on webcam so we could be rich
together whether you agree or disagree
with what I did their loyalty submission
and love for me doesn't matter you know
what's interesting now we have him
explaining what was really going on in
the back that makes like now you
understand what he's saying here which
is like basically that he's sexy right
we were always reading between the lines
right yeah because well sorry I just
gotta let it play listen to what these
guys react to this you cannot reject the
results and the results are simple my
girlfriends would do more for me than 99
of men's wives would do for them so I
don't know if this was on his actual
site or not well real quick what's
what's wrong with that if they're an
illegal age just shoot me now in the
head this guy's name is stymie by the
way
and uh real quick what's wrong with that
like are you absolutely broken right now
I'm pretty sure he just described human
trafficking I think people don't word
for word I don't think people know what
that really is not to defend him or
anything I mean he's he's dumb for not
being able to see what was just laid out
in front of him wait there's more stymie
and Brad wait there's more this is new
this is short wait hold on I gotta see
this stymie podcast all right I was
absolutely Sauced up but I do want to
point out one thing you did have your
plan of y'all I'm gonna be a gangster
I'm gonna call this guy out you didn't
do any of that you actually got on your
hands and knees and sucked this guy's
dick for an hour and a half which is
cool now I'm gonna disrespect you first
of all we have proof that's not well I
guess during the anyway whatever but we
were talking about that [ __ ] Cherry
little [ __ ] rat who says that kind of
[ __ ] I did it what are my hands go ahead
say it again
what I do in my hands and knees okay
okay I'll smack you okay take it back
I'm gonna send back a thousand two take
it send me that thousand dollars back
too by the way [ __ ] I'll smack the [ __ ]
out of you by the way okay Bradley hangs
with the wrong people he really does
yeah oh my God and you guys will see
where the con this guy have you ever
seen like a dumber looking more pathetic
face [ __ ] little weaseline they don't
exist what's wrong with human
trafficking he just sounds smart
real quick it just sounds like a good
idea
stymie I love this name stymie because
stymie means like
stunted which he is in his in both in
both stature and development
clearly he did not eat his Wheaties
I I was looking into something later in
this
no that's a stepper one yeah but what
was it about I don't know I only saw
that clip I don't know they were talking
about how
he was gonna try to challenge Andrew I
guess and he he stymie thought he just
sucked his dick I don't know what he was
talking about but Bradley should have
[ __ ] smashed him into a diamond or
something and
warm like a like a [ __ ] necklace and
like I don't know enough about sex
trafficking I don't know enough about
this to even speak on as like a
professional I'm not in that like Realm
but apparently it's a type of session
called like lover boy whereas like you
get girls you convince them to want to
work with you you do know a lot about
this though yeah I was looking into it
last night yo
yo
yo
yay you [ __ ] did research you read
like a video page bro did you do
research for the full send podcast gay
beta
full send bro
means go in do it live
hello
dude are you so [ __ ] lame like you
actually do work to make this podcast
like wait you can read what a nerd you
can read dude you did a lot of research
on this bro maybe you're sex trafficking
you know a lot about this kind of
suspicious
I love that
yeah
because I knew we're gonna come in this
box
y'all should maybe you should do a
little bit of research before you shave
your [ __ ] head and dedicate your life
to him dude
and one thing that we mean did he
already get a tattoo I wonder
oh yeah yeah probably
Well he kind of shaved his head in a way
which me and Hassan have been joking
about it but I actually don't think it's
a joke is that Andrew is grooming Aiden
no I totally agree with you actually
because you made a really good point in
your video about it and when you hear
him talk about how he manipulates the
women you he would 100 that's something
he would do he's just treating Aiden
like one of his cam girls
I mean he has like a large audience so
it's so useful to him him so much it's a
he's a large audience it's exactly his
demographic right
uh Alyssa said by the way CeCe Sicily
Sicily thank you for the gifted 10
gifted Alyssa says there's this
misconception that human trafficking is
CD characters who steal women off the
street like those Facebook posts like
gangs are putting yellow ropes on your
car to make
Marcus Steele yeah I mean I'm sure that
happens but I'm sure that's like rare
like rare rare rare rare rare
but yeah
oh that's the wrong video
and I just wanted to be like a weird a
weird thing so apparently it is a form
of sex trafficking which is like you're
getting a girl to fall in love with you
and if all I'm saying is if what he put
on his website right there
is actually true then like it's a
mission it's self-immission to like
doing that yeah I don't think that's
enough but yeah stymie again oh my God
Stamey's awesome bro Bradley's just
saying like all I'm saying is like if
this is true this is [ __ ] right yeah
right like we all agree they're like
what's so bad about it pretty much word
for word the definition of a spec like a
special technique of human trafficking
yeah it's called Loverboy yeah he goes
he goes can we all agree that this is
[ __ ] up he's like um
sounds like a cool dude I mean he's
smart I'm just been facts you know good
choices it's kind of Sigma Behavior
she's over 18. it's all good
well then then he'd be like well is
what's the legal age in Romania is 15.
it's all good all good whatever he's not
breaking the law this time is
coconuts and Barbados yeah for sure yo
we got a meme stymie I hate that little
[ __ ] he's for sure the dumbest no he
is such an idiot he's the dumbest now
that's a that's an award-winning job I
mean they're all kind of dumb you know
but he's the dumbest for sure like I
don't think he's a special breed
excluding Bradley who we love who's a
friend of the show if you added
all those IQs up I'd be surprised if it
hit three digits
what about um what about our
what about our other boy yeah that you
love in their best
oh he's not there Stevie see Steve will
do it people do he's not in the room oh
okay well no I would never insult Steve
will do it right he's a good guy
by the way he messed with me he wants to
come on the show with Bradley you I
think that'd be awesome right come down
yeah sure we should do that I'm not
actually gonna message him that's enough
but yeah no I mean obviously the girls
would have to wear money out over here
I see or maybe I'll have to make a new
one I'll think about it just have it say
Steve will do it you're a [ __ ] no you
should personalize it'd be like Eva is
out of Steve will do its League
Steve will suck these nuts
yeah we definitely need a pockets of
stymie and coconuts and Barbados that
would be fire that's gold because I feel
like in the manosphere basically they
like what whoever's Dumber right like
whoever's the dumbest most uninformed
it's like It's gotta be like proudly
dumb yes that's what it's about right
yes so we get those two together man
Unstoppable kind of [ __ ] I mean I'm
assuming that but then that's the thing
that gets crazy was like is it Ben just
is it just all hearsay because like all
the other [ __ ] this guy says that they
just don't like that he's saying it or
would they stack anything against them
that they could anyways you know what
I'm saying I don't know you just don't
know bro
it's like well yeah you don't know if
you don't look I don't read anything so
I'm hoping that some of this [ __ ] is
reaching them because at this point it's
kind of undeniable oh my God you just
never know bro
just never know they're just gonna when
he gets convicted if he gets convicted I
guess I shouldn't get too far ahead of
myself but uh they're just gonna say
that it was all he was framed yeah I
mean that was just like they'll just
move much out there now yeah public no
it's the Matrix so many people came
together to frame this one guy that they
couldn't give a [ __ ] about unless he's
just his ideas are just too dangerous we
just we just want to keep men down like
right woke men is dangerous to society
cannot have people making poorly thought
out Matrix analogies online anymore
be stupid and mean we have to crack down
on this now I mean that's why they love
him because you know he teaches kids not
to take accountability you know young
men so that's that is kind of appealing
right so my response my first video
about Adam Ross was Aiden Ross attacked
my wife and threatened me which is like
way over the top fun because one of his
bodyguards was like I'll beat him up if
I see him he wasn't serious and then
also one of his dudes said ela's ugly so
Aiden actually didn't say any of these
all right I apologize yeah and so I
apologize for my existence my ugly
existence sorry yeah yeah it's good that
you apologize for that
[ __ ] up what you do
yeah and so Aiden made this really
comment he's like dude this title is
[ __ ] up like this title is insane and
so I and when I reacted that I said I'm
gonna name my next video if he thinks
that's crazy which is the next one I'm
gonna name it Aiden Ross sent me Anthrax
in the mail and sure enough
because I wanted to I wanted to impress
him
sure enough my next one and it's still
monetized by the way it's still green
Aiden Ross sent me Anthrax in the mail
awesome yeah
wow Jacob thank you so much for that he
says can I get a big happy birthday to
my pal Danny Chuck buns
and a shout to the small pecker Society
Shout It Out shot Packers it's all dirty
happy Birthday Danny
yep
there it is so that's kind of the eight
and raw [ __ ] that's been going on and
then I made this Urgent Message to Aiden
Ross but uh you forgot to mention that
in all of this he actually I saw him
react to one of your videos and he was
like
he's super cool about it he was super
cool and actually we connected we
followed each other on Twitter I was
like Ethan he said you were funny like
what else matters nothing what do we do
here in life well once someone says that
and he said it like three or four times
then I'm already adopt him
um
actually we connected in Twitter and
he's he's wants to connect
I don't know how what connecting means
because I've seen how
him and and Andrew were sitting in that
hotel room and I'm not going to make
that kind of connection yeah I don't
know if I'm gonna be okay with that kind
of connection yeah don't worry not
interested he's a young guy he's still
you know figuring himself out and I
think he wants a father figure exactly
he's looking to imprint that was like
why he like kind of just like became
little miniature now he's going to
become a miniature Ethan he's gonna he
just needs to bleach his shaved hair now
he's a bleach of shaped hair he needs to
put on a few pounds slides and shorts
slides and shorts all the time with
socks you know what I mean just start
dressing like you yeah when you put it
that way I understand why men don't uh
yeah
but trust me I I know the way yeah so
then I made the stupid little [ __ ] post
video because I was I've been so
obsessed with this Matrix meme how they
actually like think this is it's just
crazy to me and so I made this video
urging Aiden Ross to listen to me he's
in the matrix it's an Urgent Message
I'll just show you a bit of Aiden Ross
if you know Aiden Ross please make sure
he sees this video
now a tragedy just before Aiden Ross he
was banned on Twitch because somebody
went into his live stream and sabotaged
him what happened was he was doing some
GTA 5 role playing and somebody dressed
up like Adolf Hitler
ready for that and he did get banned and
you know why that happened most people
are missing the true story here do you
understand
The Matrix is after you Aiden Ross and
this is why I'm making this urgent
urgent message to you yeah so I go on to
say that you know and I just make this
really powerful uh analogy that Andrew
Tate is Agent Smith he Aiden Ross's Neo
of course and I'm Morpheus and I'm ready
I'm ready to take him out and show him
the way
so that's a really I think uh hopefully
he saw that and it got to him
also yeah uh thank you to n Arthur free
Andrew and Tristan look at lethan
Decline and know that you'll look like
him if you don't listen to Tay is this
serious I think so why'd you just give
me five bucks idiot wait a minute it's a
joke because that's free Andrew Tate
look at lethan decline
kind of gives me a joke Vibe no but my
haters do it no that's literally what
they call it yeah yeah all right well
you used to say that before then one
that's really funny I I will say they
call me eat eat and decline
that one is good yes okay but now I'm
I'm taking it back it's Ethan
[Applause]
[Music]
declining in size
uh-huh
thanks for the five bucks
thanks dumbass you [ __ ] idiot thanks
for the five I'm surprised you have any
money left after getting flea so hard by
Andrew hey how's uh how's Hustler
University going is it is the is class
still in session when the professor's in
jail or are you guys on hiatus
donate another five bucks and tell me
he's got money to donate because he's
not paying taxes yeah is this in Bic did
you don't tell me you converted Bitcoin
for that five bro because
true that crypto [ __ ] no they're gonna
go to him for it man
yeah uh moving on it's getting really
late how long have we been going DBI
uh for two hours 36 minutes this is
awesome 2023 is our year stars out of
the picture and it's me and Aiden
pounding up I hear this picture yeah
exactly even though it's an edit I still
hear it the crypto [ __ ] yo you're in
trouble you're in trouble the end of his
career really it all started here you
know and I think that enough is you know
a reason to make up with Aiden to be
right here it's true there's respect
there it looks so gay
by the way I also noticed a pattern of
Aiden Ross like all of his homies are
going to jail Tory Lanez is in jail for
shooting someone Andrew Tate's in jail
for uh
it's sex trafficking a lot and then when
his bodyguard threatened to beat me up
on site I was like good let's get your
other homie in jail that'll be three
yeah anyway moving on we got one more
story here Logan
first coffee Zilla hello gang
I don't think we ever talked about this
either my goodness all right this was
also during break yeah it was so broken
though
[Laughter]
say that again Macho broken though
what the [ __ ] is this much oh Broken Oh
what does that mean what
it's like broken like very very broken
much oh broken uh yeah
that is dumb
oh yeah bro
okay God all right I gotta pee again
guys sorry I know me
oh yeah all right I'll be right back
I'll be right back and then we'll talk
about Logan coffee Zilla it's the subs
dude I think I found that haters uh
Twitter account
oh
oh man today
hmm I'm saying they're probably coming
for Ethan full force on Tick Tock
because they have nothing else to do
daddy's not around Oh Daddy isn't around
to direct The Horde
yeah I put that dude's uh YouTube name
into Google with just Twitter behind it
and a Tristan tape thread is the first
thing so I'm assuming he's a reply guy
there's nothing wrong with being a reply
he's like an anti-love he's hate right
to the right people yeah give us five
dollars more to confirm though yeah Ben
Arthur
um if you could
it's probably fuming right now
[Music]
I'm just trying to you know do a little
research I know these guys don't aren't
familiar with the concept but
anyways what were we talking about
before Ethan interrupted before oh right
the new Star Wars the new Star Wars yeah
yeah yeah yeah sorry did you finish it I
didn't but it is really good okay and
then I noticed in the background of the
third episode there's starkiller's armor
and I was like oh that's [ __ ] nerd
[ __ ] I'm in
star kill it
not not yeah
interesting Starkiller is not you no no
no no no no I'm with an A but the the
Star Wars video game there was a guy
named Starkiller I was it's anyway who
he's based on yeah yeah I see it based
on a true story yeah
yes maybe watching uh the documentary
Hunters with Pacino you know I started
it and it was really good I was about to
tell you to watch that yeah that first
team got me hooked I was like holy [ __ ]
yeah I I've binged the uh second season
because it came out oh how was it it was
all right yeah it wasn't it wasn't like
the first one but uh it's pretty good
you know good you guys know what I was
watching over break what'd you watch
Ian's twitch stream it's [ __ ] awesome
Ian's on Twitch baby [ __ ] love is
Twitch thank you I love his twitch
you know what Ian and I went and saw
that I think are we still the only ones
who've seen it yeah we went yeah we went
and saw Avatar
and thoughts
oh my God that was super loud
did you just hit the
thanks for watching or whatever the
technical oh technical difficult that
was extremely rad why was that yeah that
probably raptured everyone oh my God
that really hurt yeah it didn't come to
my uh headphones so I guess I didn't
hear it anyways uh Ian and I went and
saw Avatar and uh it was all right it
was all right he didn't liked it more
than me I I was entertained though I
liked it more than I thought I was I had
very low expectations so I think it it
cleared the bar quite easily
but Ian is he's he's embraced the way of
water are you talking about Avatar too
yeah man I'm not watching that [ __ ]
thank you
you're lost dude did you really love it
Ian like on give it an honest rating one
through two honestly I am very much blue
pilled he's blue pill one through ten be
honest I believe you well I the way I
described it is that my expectations
were like at the bottom of the ocean I
hated Avatar one I walked out really
yeah I didn't like it so I was not
excited I kept telling Dan I'm like I
don't really want to go watch this movie
uh but because of that because they
delivered a decent I was like this is
the greatest movie ever made I love this
movie foreign
either I think
you go see I like it 3D the whole deal
yeah we did the the full shebang when we
went and saw it it's a it's a cinematic
experience I will that's a 10. Ian loves
Avatar are you really giving it a 10 I'm
not giving it a 10. then you got that
sounds like a ten because for because as
I said if you can't go see it like that
I'm I'm never watching it again yeah
yeah that's that's the only way I'd want
to watch them oh so it's like it's like
a Disney ride or something like that yes
okay that that's an interesting the
first one was also like that right
because I think that people said if you
didn't watch it with all the iMacs and
everything it was like which is why can
I say something yeah doesn't that mean
it's a bad movie it's
like if you need to watch it in like a
100 million dollar screen with like shh
[ __ ] seats that shake and wind
blowing in your face and Miss like if
you can't sit at home and you're like
wow this movie [ __ ] sucks doesn't
that mean it's a bad movie yeah what's
doing all the work
did you yeah you could go do a 40s
we did not do the 4D we just did we just
did normal 3D so we weren't getting
splashed in the face or anything
um but I will say the thing is I [ __ ]
do not like the 3D thing I've seen
several movies like that over the years
and I do I don't like it I don't like
being obligated to wear that the whole
time James Cameron is the only director
who knows how to utilize it correctly it
it was definitely cool I agree the first
one was the only good VR I've ever seen
or 3D yeah and and this one he he
utilizes it in a very good way and the
movie was shot for IMAX and so seeing it
in IMAX is
so that this movie has zero
rewatchability and anyone who watches it
at home because it's not gonna be in
theaters forever right is gonna think
it's gonna [ __ ] suck it's not gonna
[ __ ] suck but without without all of
that without the Cinematic experience
it's definitely didn't you just write
like a good story
imagine that you go to James Cameron
movie he had enough time yeah thank you
like you know what I mean yeah it's like
10 years I'll say the story was was
better in this one okay that's good
because it's like you have 10 years and
all the money in the world literally
yeah and like it'd be cool if like it
was just better
yeah if it was like blue people but it
was about something like yeah like
better I mean it is it's about something
it's very ham-fisted and on the nose
it's about imperialism and listen to the
way Dan the hater listen to this this is
a good movie if Dan's having this I
don't know about that
Avatar you know it's no Ian Ian's 100
right I agree wait I agree you agree
with what if Dan's talking about it this
way that means if I'm defending it at
all well Dan did say he liked it which
was surprising go ahead Dan give it let
me hear your your speech okay if you go
and see it in IMAX on a 3D screen with
like the [ __ ] full full-blown
experience
you're gonna have like
an eight out of 10 movie going
experience three and a half hours yeah
it is really [ __ ] long you know a
minute past three hours though it
definitely feels long you know what's
really fun the Harry Potter ride at
Universal Studios and guess what if I
watch that screen back at home it
wouldn't be very fun it's it's better
than that it's better than the Harry
Potter writers Universe I have a
question I have a question did you get
up to pee at any point
no I actually I blew through the whole
freaking thing did you get it drank
popcorn anything like that I did I did
have did you wish it was over at any
point like where you're like okay okay
no it really it it I'm not gonna say it
doesn't feel long it's long but it's a
well-paced movie I think it's much
better constructed than the original I
would actually go as far as can you tell
us one bad thing about it yeah the uh
story is very predictable and you've
seen this story a million times before
um sounds awesome it's it's basically
the first movie but he like did it again
this is what I was about to say the
movie is low-key oh it's it's horrible
it's repetitive you've seen it before
but I don't see it for the story
but that point is couldn't he just make
a good story are you guys saying that
this should have been Avatar one not
avatars no Avatar this is Avatar one
because it's the same movie it's just
been in the can for 10 years because the
first one is so what I wanted was the
soft launch
a soft reboot because you you probably
could just start with this one and not
see the first one and you wouldn't
really be lost there's a couple Concepts
I guess that you should be a little
familiar with but it could have been
introduced in the second movie why I
loved it so much is I loved it I he
loved it I loved it because yeah Ian
really did like it I feel like nowadays
it's so so rare to get like a massive
giant budget like film go to the cinema
experience that isn't a damn Marvel
movie like a huge Blockbuster that takes
over it's so rare so it's nice to do
that and it wasn't superhero stuff this
time it was like it's a separate thing
and I loved it I loved it you don't get
those very often there it is wow
I don't know what to say Ian Ian and Dan
endorse and listen ooh boys would you
watch your avatar porn yes or no porn
did I stutter
hell no I I find the the navi to be uh
kind of creepy to be honest but I mean
the CG the CG is well done but um yeah
the people that find them hot it's a
little there's a lot is Sigourney Weaver
in it so this is a trip she is in it but
not as herself she did the mocap and
voice for one of the characters but like
one of like the teenage characters yeah
so Sigourney Weaver is playing like a 17
year old girl blue girl what no no she
was great she was great can I I want to
read uh Adrian said I saw Avatar blazed
in 3D IMAX and almost had a salmon Ian
experience from the almost stimulation
funny also another donation which I'll
respond to Kelsey said no response to
Andrew Callahan apology video I mean
look there's so much to talk about
there's a lot so to talk about y'all
want to go watch it Andrew Callahan put
out a statement
if you want to watch it I go check it
out and um
I don't know what do you want me to say
we're trying to have a fun show here you
know what's the commentary you're
looking for here
yeah exactly oh I want to say
is that like addressing it and saying
that you need to learn do all these
things is the first step and I think
next is just we got to see the action
you know yeah yeah action will be
louder than that yeah because I
personally feel like with the Chris
D'Elia thing I'm super Disturbed after
the this latest video that came out oh I
didn't I think I didn't even mention
that it was a new crystallia documentary
that hit YouTube called was it the
problem with crystally or something
right it's an hour long but like the guy
got in touch with the women he got in
touch with he got receipts on new [ __ ]
he's been up to and boy
tattoo his initials on him it's like a
full-on um Nexium level of like stuff if
anyone but
I what I learned from watching that one
is that during if you guys remember
Chris Dalia put out a video on his
podcast or whatever it was that he's
like
acknowledging that he has a problem and
he's gonna learn and do all this stuff
to improve himself and apparently he was
continuing to do all the same [ __ ] while
putting that video and after yeah dude
this video is crazy definitely a good
watch Disturbed after watching this one
and by good watch I mean it's like
it's well put together and it's it's
very interesting compelling obviously
it's disturbing how [ __ ] depraved he
is but I definitely highly recommend it
this dude Kyle Anderson put it out it's
an hour long and obviously this dude put
in the work
uh to make a great video can I say it's
good and this guy's [ __ ] disgusting
he's horrific and [ __ ] anyone who's ever
worked with him yeah here's me
Chris Delia
right in the side it's just been like
one after the other and now you know
obviously now Justin orland is in there
bro the Justin roiling [ __ ] is so it's
been a lot crazy
[Music]
like crazy
[Music]
I think I so with Justin there was some
texts that came out I saw him for the
first time yesterday and when I read
those I was like oh he's done done like
done done buried and done like there's
no coming back for this let me just show
you like if an AI could put together the
worst conversation that someone could
have even sometimes he said jailbait he
says jailbait he even says her name like
you couldn't go into a laboratory like
you said an AI yeah and be like let me
write a text that will incriminate me as
much as possible and make me look as bad
as possible
yeah that's tight level of a self-report
you guys want me to read this so I mean
I guess you better know about it this
sucks though dude this [ __ ] sucks
wait did anybody censor this yeah yeah
yeah okay wait what did you need to
censor now he drops the F slur in there
oh oh oh I don't know if YouTube will
not good job good job thank you for yeah
yeah yeah lots of slurs too like oh yeah
like where did those come from
alcoholics like people aren't even mad
about the slurs like they're not even
talking about that at least yeah that's
that's low on the list yeah right
like if anyone else had these DMS Leak
with those slurs it'd be a big problem
for them people didn't even mention that
[ __ ] in the context of this
it's kind of just crazy with Justin
because
so many [ __ ] people are
gonna be affected by this professionally
like he has so many projects Rick and
Morty solar opposites which is on Hulu
he's got this big art project he's
working on he has his [ __ ]
um
he has this huge video game company that
they just launched a game to great
success and all and what's crazy is all
that [ __ ] is like centered it's his
voice you know I mean it's his
personality
it's not like you can go on without him
I feel like
they're gonna try
um no way Adult Swim just pulls the plug
on Rick and Morty they make way too much
money off of that [ __ ] I think they'll
recast him dude after reading this yeah
I think what's gonna happen is they're
going to announce
it's got to be coming that they're going
to part ways with them because dude you
just got to read this text
crazy
and it's just sad like why dude like why
bro
did you really think that people weren't
going to see that like why why would you
do this
oh yeah and the main story that broke
was that he was charged a felony for
yeah domestic abuse and imprison
wrongful imprisonment
and he's still and still going through
the court yeah so he could potentially
go to jail for that one
like jail like he could go to [ __ ]
jail jail
yep
guys what do you want me to say about
Andrew like he talked about it you've
seen it I've talked about it he made his
apology the whole thing is it is what it
is you guys come on well I guess you
should say you talked about it
and uh Ethan Klein or was it the client
video yeah I did or no it was over the
brave day you talked about but even if I
didn't it's like you know yeah I did
talk about I acknowledged it I talked
about it I just you know what I mean I'm
done with that whole situation in my
opinion I just it is what it is you guys
I'm talking about Justin Roiland here
he's my friend
okay
like
yeah
all right you guys ready for this
can you write a song
there's there's two okay
can you write a song about nine
this was a girl I guess who was doing
actually commission for I feel like it's
too perfect
they said let's do a poll I mean this
this one's insane insanity this one on
the bottom is like [ __ ] crazy dude
I gotta read it
can you write a song about nine decks of
different sizes and ethnic Origins
hanging above your face I didn't let us
describe how they each splatter you with
semen but important the larger message
of this song is about how we're all the
same and no more racism who's the lead
character why does he she have to find
you know what yeah this one's not even
that bad I love that
good point
this one here well I mean whatever would
you do like to do okay so so this girl
is apparently 16 right and he was 34 at
the time of this conversation would you
do video game reviews and stuff like
that I bet you'd be good at it she said
yeah just playing games and [ __ ] then
once you turn 18 you can just start cam
whoring
straight up that's grooming
he literally wrote when you turn 18.
I'm speechless I can't even do well just
wait he goes oh yes sorry I'm at the
airport it's insane in the membrane what
time is it there 11 30. oh it's so great
I don't know why he busts into like the
racist Chinese stick he goes It's So
rape me so Chinese
she ignores it because it's weird I have
school tomorrow oh school tomorrow oh no
[ __ ] my life I like how she's like yeah
I'm in high school
you should just run away from home and
go into sex slavery you [ __ ]
f word f slur [ __ ]
what
wait it's actually worse
it's actually worse if you can believe
it he says is it cool being jailbait yes
sir
does the FBI follow you around and
arrest them and you sleep with
maybe I will I want to meet you in real
life jailbait so I can't help you not be
a homo I'm an Atlanta drunk I thought
there was more
but
that's just what he wrote in a DM with a
random girl who was 16.
oh geez Rick oh [ __ ] it just sucked it
sucks I know there's been a lot of uh
there's been a lot of that
what a [ __ ] creepy ass weirdo dude
though I mean what the [ __ ] no this
that's like next that's probably of all
the cancellations and all this [ __ ]
that's leaked like that is probably the
craziest DM I've ever seen leaked yeah
foreign
s left and right we need Andrew Tate man
who else is going to Rally the men
oh yeah
men they're doing impossible things yeah
they're doing a possible things they're
DMX 16 year olds trying to get them into
Camp bit to become cam girls we are men
We Are Men 16 just run away from home
and do sex slavery
come be my sex slave I'm a man
and men need sex
we are citizens we are dreamers
we are citizen
we are we are Christians we are Jewish
we are Muslim we are Hindu we are
religious we are secular we are gay we
are straight We Are Young we are older
we are women We Are Men We Are citizens
we are dreamers thank you thank you we
got another one basically yeah
that one drags on a bit he's got to work
on the pacing a little bit like he's
he's rushing he's really fast well it's
a long speech he went through all the
way give it room to breathe I am a
Muslim I am Jewish I am black I am gay I
am gay see Cuomo nude just to let it
hang out there I am gay
yeah I don't know what to say honestly
about this whole [ __ ] thing it's like
one after the other man
here is uh the choice that men are faced
with today which way should we insecure
Western male go mommy issues
so so true actually so so so [ __ ]
true Grand mommy issues maybe I know for
sure that Tate's got those daddy issues
that's what it all comes from
Peterson I don't know what's his issue
man he's just [ __ ] up that dude just
rage posts on Twitter all day like all
day so unwell it doesn't stop
I did not the Twitter suit he's got
great yeah dude his Twitter suit was
wild he's got Grandma issues
oh
oh nailed it that's a great [ __ ]
nailed Segway to uh I guess the the
hairy Prince Harry [ __ ]
you don't remember
oh my God wait I think I erased it on
accident when I was putting the dock
together can you can someone restore it
um
now it's gone
Ethan you can you just go to a previous
version before that yeah it just takes a
while yeah
I don't know man
somebody said Gulf issues I don't
understand
I don't understand how can it be
happening so much
what the stuff with all the men
I will say what's what happening with
Andrews like or not Andrew what's
happening with Justin is like on another
level it's like R Kelly's [ __ ]
the joke that's coming out Ian just sent
it in our uh
Discord chat here
so um oh yeah [ __ ] a Prince Harry
do I call him Prince that [ __ ]
he renounced his [ __ ] right
okay so he made this
autobiographical book and apparently
it's the best-selling non-fiction book
of all time in the first like who who
gives a [ __ ] do people care about this
kid
Prince Harry man you ain't no Brits just
Harry
I'm getting it I'm just getting sick of
hearing about them yeah I mean Tim and
his wife Megan I'm getting sick of it no
they really like they wanted to get out
of the spotlight only to make like 9
million new TV shows
the spotlight let's go make a Netflix go
let's go write a book let's go [ __ ]
do Oprah and Ellen I'll just I don't
care
I mean I like that he's kind of helping
ruin the reputation of the British royal
family like that's kind of based I guess
that is based
um Kelsey said all love we love H3 and
TF the only reason we brought up
Callahan is because he did a recent
apology not covered by Thin yeah I mean
it just came out and
I just urge you guys to to watch it you
know
I don't feel like dissecting it right
now
I just feel like it doesn't
matter like
people are either gonna
um take him at his word or accept that
he's changing or whatever or people are
gonna find if there were definitely a
few things there that he could have not
said
um but bottom line is I think we gotta
see
his actions people are [ __ ] so wrong
though I talked about it and like people
were even reporting it
like I guess I I don't know the whole
thing sucked how like people reporting
what I said and
I guess I should have known that that
would happen
but uh I mean yeah
I literally said on my I don't need it
[ __ ] appease chat shut up
that's the real answer yeah there you go
let's talk about Prince Harry's dick
yeah so again and like this dude is
giving he's saying way too much listen
to this [ __ ] from his audiobook my penis
was oscillating between extremely
sensitive and borderline traumatized the
last place I wanted to be was Frost
nipples down
I've been trying some home remedies
including one recommended by a friend
she urged me to reply Elizabeth Arden
cream
my mom used that on her lips you want me
to put that on my todger It Works Harry
trust me Mike todger hey oi you want to
put the lip balm on my charger
my uncle
put it on your Taja
dude these English people are goofy as
hell sorry
I found a tube and the minute I opened
it the smell transported me through time
I thought as if my mother was right
there in the room
and I took a smidge and applied it down
there why is he saying it like that this
dude I was thinking about my mom and she
used to put it on her lips and the smell
transported me right back to her and
then I put it in my on my dick
traumatized
dude you sang Too Much my penis was
oscillating between extremely sensitive
Prince Harry maybe he's talking about
Prince Albert
thank you my opinion the good Lord
traumatized people
faithful subjects
my penises oscillating between sensitive
and painful
my mommy's Oogie Boogie
that on my knick-knack I've been trying
some home remedies including one
recommended by a friend she urged me to
apply Elizabeth Arden cream hear me now
the people
[Music]
my mother's lips
it works Harry trust me it works Harry
my mother said I found a tube as she
tubed my Taja with her ookie bookie
a knick-knack paddy whack mother
obviously my mother was right there in
the room she was right there in the room
God saved the queen of waste God found
the queen already forgot oh no God's
like hell down there why does he deliver
that line like that it really doesn't
turn there there's like a half beat
applied it down there right there this
dude is so wild for putting this out
there my penis was oscillating between
excuses
my charger is oscillating without my
toucher put this on my touch
listen loyal subjects hear me now I told
you my todger is oscillating
you know he says that he has so much
stuff written that he had to take out
that he already has enough for a second
book oh I can't wait thank goodness
do we get a chapter on his paja yeah
like 38. tell me more about him please I
need to know if he's 38. we also who's
buying this [ __ ] though some of y'all
are buying this and I want to know who
because it's the best seller ever
wait bestseller ever it's the
best-selling non non uh fiction book
like in the first week or whatever ever
ever ever
it's pretty wild really yes fact check
me
cha
can you get a mashup of the todger with
the Grandma's pubes I dreamed I saw my
maternal grandmother sitting by the bank
I'm gonna have to edit that which was
awesome yeah just you could just see uh
yeah her genital region was exposed
dimly it had the appearance of a thing
of hair she was stroked Prince Harry's
Memoir spare
has become a record-breaking success
with First Day sales that exceeded some
of the publishing's biggest hits
including
books I've never heard of spare sold
more than one point sold more than one
we've never heard of Barack Obama
including yeah okay all right you know I
thought it was a book called Barack
you know penguin
penguin I'm the like Book Company
it was their fastest selling non-fiction
books spare sold more than 1.43 million
copies in all formats including
pre-orders well hold on because it did I
read I know yeah I got it yeah it was
the world record for the fastest sound
non-fiction book of all time in 24 hours
there you go
I hope you all enjoyed reading about his
todger
did you buy the book yeah be honest you
guys I need to know how many are out
there ten percent I guess they're who
are they who
there's there's a lot of them out there
I don't know who they are down there I
don't know one person that would buy
this book so I'm just curious where are
they all my penis was oscillating
between extreme sensitive
I think we got I think we already got a
a shoe and finalist for
2023 sound bites
down there town there Target
seven percent of our audiences they
bought the book okay but I'll be honest
we've done a lot of polls and this is
like a total blowout like you don't get
yeah more disparity than this
yeah pretty much
Mike Taja my grandmother touched my Taja
she lightly applied the knip knack paddy
whack sauce
did they say in Britain
aluminum aluminum aluminum I had a I had
a witty witty and I had a whoop whoop
when my nanny put a tajiwaji on my neck
down there down there
have you ever told you warji with your
own mother put a taji waji on your
knick-knack they do rhyme a lot I feel
like I told you I told you what
I said
[Music]
all right all right we gotta wrap it up
it's super later and it's five here
thank you guys it's so good to be back
so nice to spend this afternoon with
y'all thanks for tuning in hope you guys
enjoyed and we will be back as usual
per our regular programming Wednesday
Wednesday uh oh interesting Friday
Anthony fantano's in the house
kind of exciting that's a guest that
we've been long requested hoping for
yeah a lot of people requested that
so that'll be fun
uh but yeah other than that normal week
be back
all right it is yeah I was looking
forward to it right
it is
what you thinking about I was wondering
if I should talk about the thing or not
but
I think it's too late
yeah it's like I might as well talk
about I might as well I'll just say it
I was it's really sad so I wanted to
wait till the end of the show
so anyway the day I'm just gonna get I'm
just gonna get through it really fast so
the day that we came back from vacation
I noticed that or I noticed before we
left for our family vacation that
Shredder just seemed off
he was shaking and he was laying on me
and like he wouldn't get off like he was
just laying on me and he wasn't eating
for a couple days so I've just had this
feeling that
there was something off
so he stayed with my mom when we went on
vacation for three days
she took him to the vet
he got a checkup the doctor was like he
looks fine his vitals are all fine
they did a blood test on him and the
next day the doctor called my mom and
said he's having stage four kidney
failure like his kidney is
completely [ __ ]
um and so right now he's in a doggy
Hospital
he's been there this is going to be
the third day
the third day
he's getting his kidney flushed
and um
you know I've been crying non-stop since
I got home I just been
so devastated by it
and
he's only five I don't know it's like
it's just so devastating
that
uh
I don't I don't I can't talk about it
too much
I've been crying my eyes out since we
got home but uh
but he's
basically the situation was like
depending on how advanced his kidney
disease is
um
is how much time he has left
and so the prognosis was like two weeks
or maybe a year at best is what the
doctors told me
but it seemed like he was really [ __ ]
like his kidney was like
not functioning like off the charts just
like not
cleaning his blood at all like total
kidney failure
he's only five dude
and so
um
so the only reason I'm not crying in a
total shambles right now is actually we
talked to the doctor right before we got
here
and I thought he was going to live like
two weeks like I've just been crying and
I've just been devastated anybody knows
anything about me
and Eva
is that Shredder is like the world to me
I mean he means so much to us
he's been with us for so long
he's our first baby
and he just I I can't even describe it
like the dog means he means so much to
us I see he's like a family member he's
not just he's not a dog he's like I know
maybe it sounds stupid to some people
he's like a person to me
like there's just this incredible bond
that we have that like we just
understand each other on like a whole
nother level
ah
I never knew that I could have like a
relationship so deep with a dog
and I used to think all the time about
how like [ __ ] I'm gonna be a mess if
anything ever happened to him but I'm
gonna I can I guarantee at least like 10
good years
and I can't believe that
in five years he's so sick uh but the
anyway when we got right when we got off
we were in the parking lot of our office
and the doctor said that
the kidney disease is not as advanced as
as I as it we feared it would be and she
thinks
that tomorrow we're going to be able to
bring them home he needs like chronic
care now we're gonna have to give him
like IVs and medicine and [ __ ] to keep
like his blood clean because his kidney
is like not functioning
but she thinks
that he'll be able to live like a year
that's like the best case scenario
and it's just been in mourning like I'm
just happy I'll be [ __ ] so happy if
we can just bring them home and have a
year together
to just have like
it's hard to talk about
yeah but Alfredo's just Alfredo's here
so
foreign
I just wanted you guys to know that
because it's going to become pretty
obvious as he gets sick
and there's just one dog with us
but we're gonna pick them up tomorrow
and bring them home and I just hope that
we have
I'd be I'd be you know thrilled to just
have at least a couple of good months
where he's you know not feeling sick and
we can be happy and just live our normal
lives
before he gets really sick
I should She's So Young that's the part
that really [ __ ] me up like I just
wasn't ready to say goodbye to him
like if he was older I would
it would be easier to accept that he
lived like a full life
he really is like our third baby I don't
know how to describe it I mean
anyway I just wanted to tell you guys
because it's going to be obvious and
you're always gonna have to tell you
guys eventually anyway
the good news is this morning I thought
we would have two weeks with him and I
was like I don't even know how I'm gonna
do the show today I'm in [ __ ] wreck
and I called the doctor back and talked
to a different doctor and she said that
the kidney disease well they think he
might have an infection they're hoping
that it's an infection they're giving
him antibiotics
because he has acute and chronic kidney
disease
chronic is like a progressive disease
that gets worse and then acute is like
when something happens and it makes it
suddenly really bad
so he has both
and they're trying to figure out
what's causing the acute kidney and then
hoping once they resolve that
that he'll be feeling better even though
he has kidney disease and like I said
it's
it's gonna you know
it's terminal it's just a matter of how
long
but I just hope that it's you know the
infection because if it's not I don't
know
I don't know
they found him on an IV and they testing
his blood to see like what are the
levels of the things and then like the
first night it went down we're feeling
hopeful and then this morning she said
it was went back up and then we're like
oh [ __ ] like he's [ __ ] he's [ __ ]
and then I talked to another doctor and
she said he's going to have some time at
home he can live for a while with like
if you guys take do care and do
everything by the book
so obviously we're going to give him the
best care possible and just hope that we
have a lot of time left with him
but yeah
it's been tough man
it's been really hard it's been crazy
it's been nuts dude
I just [ __ ] love that dog so much
I can't imagine like my life without him
but he anyway he's got some time left
at least that's what it sounded like the
last time we talked to see what they say
in the morning
he's a small dog I thought he's gonna
live forever like they say small dogs
live forever
he's like I was like 15 years
and then I was like the [ __ ] that was
really [ __ ] me up it was like I don't
even know if Theodore's gonna remember
now when he gets older
okay
I don't know why that [ __ ] me up so bad
anyway that's that
anyway I'm glad I did it at the end of
the show because how do you go how do
you go on from there
but I was I think I was able to be in a
decent mood today just because of that
call before the show and I just hope
that that doctor is [ __ ] right and I
hope he's got an affection and they're
treating it
all right
all right
anyway that's that so I'll see you guys
on Wednesday
you can yeah